Hello Freak bitches.
Welcome back.
Once again.
Matt flavors here and he's got his fucking reading glasses on.
So you know,
shit is about to very serious.
This episode of the Joe Rogan podcast is brought to,
I said it again,
is brought to you buy naturebox,
naturebox.
Uh,
one of my favorite new sponsors.
They make some goddamn delicious shit and uh,
send it do rectally to you for free.
If you're a one of those people that works in an office and you're,
you get annoyed at the fact that you don't have good LD snacks to eat,
that's delicious,
that you don't feel guilty about eating and you know,
the vending machines filled with crap and it's hard to fucking go to the store
and buy shit and think,
okay,
these are my snacks for work.
Way Easier to have naturebox deliver it and naturebox and deliver stuff that is
with zero trans fats,
zero high fructose corn syrup,
nothing artificial,
no artificial sweeteners.
They have like really healthy options.
And then they have shit like pretzels,
but which are very yummy,
very young,
not figs.
Oh yeah.
Good.
Cocoa almonds.
Have you had that?
A big apple pineapple.
Yeah.
The black and white granolas delicious.
They've got endless stuff on there that you and there's a nutritionalist
approved.
It's fucking delicious.
Did you get the Sriracha cashews?
Yes I did.
Did you get the step by sea pistachio?
Yes.
You get stoned sometimes you're hungry.
You're looking for something that's the perfect fucking snack people.
Yeah.
This is one you know
naturebox can set you up to,
if you have a very specific dietary requirements like low sugar or gluten free,
really,
really delicious shit free shipping anywhere in the u s naturebox is busting the
vending machines monopoly on your mid day hunger.
That's their fucking line,
not mine.
See the difference?
Try naturebox right right now and get 50% off your first box by going to
naturebox.com/rogan so for 50% off naturebox.com/rogan in joy.
You freaks because we do.
Naturebox is in fact the shit.
It's really cool cause they like any kind of the snacks.
They tell you right there like soy free dairy free.
They tell you like it's really well put it on their website and when you get it
sent to your house,
you don't even realize how easy that is.
That's like five things.
Just throw in your in your cupboard and then you have snacks the whole week
instead of like going to Mcdonald's or something like that.
I don't know.
And good shit.
It's not like you could find this stuff at the grocery store with a fucking
gonna Fund.
Sriracha cashews.
Yeah,
like they have some excellent recipes that they've concocted so I salute them.
We're also brought to you by Tang,
another podcast sponsor that I really enjoy,
but ting is a a podcast or a podcast company,
podcast sponsor that what they decided to do was make their own cell phone
company rent time on sprint,
but do it their way,
do it their way with no early termination fees,
no contracts,
just sell people service on sprint.
So you know,
you get an excellent network and give them for a choice,
the best mobile available through android and iPhone.
Leave the iPhone five on there and instead of like the way you do it at most
places,
if you go to a,
uh,
one of the bigger name cell phone companies,
what you're doing is your rent,
sort of like leasing a phone.
Like if the phone costs 200 bucks,
the iPhone has cost 200 bucks.
Pitch and iPhone costs 600 bucks,
but you paid 200 bucks and then over the course of the years of your contract,
you pay off the rest.
They don't do it that way.
A tank,
if it says 200 bucks,
it's cause it's 200 bucks.
That's it.
We're done here that you give them 200 bucks,
they give you a phone that's a wrap.
Like you see that iPhone five,
if they had 260 bucks,
that's what it actually costs and then that shit is yours.
And if you want to leave you leave,
you want to come back,
come on back.
Nobody gives a fuck.
All right.
What they're trying to do is sell you an excellent cell phone service at a
reasonable price with reasonable rules.
And they also have it set up so you only pay for the minutes that you use.
If you use one minute a month,
that's what you pay for you a hundred a hundred minutes a month.
That's what you pay for.
It's,
that's what's going to happen in the future because all these fucking goofy
rules where it's like,
you know,
go over 120 minutes and you've got this fee because you got an overage fee and
all that nonsense.
Can you imagine if one of the big name guys did that?
They would ruin everybody cause they're like,
oh yeah,
that makes a lot of sense.
Let's go to this other big name.
I think in the future,
this is the only way they're going to do it.
I really do.
I think 10 is way ahead of the curve.
They're also ahead of the curve they had on their two year anniversary.
They just for no reason just decided a slash all their prices.
They're like,
we got better deals so we're going to give better deals to you guys.
All the prices on data.
If you're a heavy user or a heavy Internet user,
especially the data prices on on ting are fantastic.
98% of people would save money with tank 98% that's real numbers I think go
their website,
but they are inherently have some statistics.
$21 is the average monthly bill per device per 10 customers.
I know you pay more than 21 bucks.
Go to rogan.ting.com and save an additional 25 bucks off of any of those new
delicious android devices.
That's Rogan dot [inaudible] dot com we are also brought to last and foremost by
on it,
o n n I t a human optimization website.
What we sell it on it is all things that we have found to improve you,
improve your mind,
improve your endurance,
improve your mood.
If we find things they prove to be good.
If we look at the research and it makes sense,
we post all that research along with references.
All this stuff that we sell,
whether it's the controversial things like Alpha brain and shroom tech and new
mood,
what you're dealing with Alpha brain and new mood.
You're dealing with these things called nootropics with nootropics are is
vitamins and nutrients that have been shown to have a positive impact on
cognitive function is very controversial stuff.
If you,
you know,
you Google Online,
you can find people that say that vitamins aren't necessary and their bullshit
and they don't do anything for you in nutrients.
All you need is what you get from your food.
Do you know how much fucking weird grasses and moss you would have to eat to get
some of the nutrients that's in something like Alpha brain?
You're not going to get it from your food man.
Like is it to have a healthy diet then just to Ed Shitty Diet and take
supplements,
ev abs off Fuckin lutely healthy diet is number one.
It's the most important thing,
but for optimization,
for optimization,
meaning making your body and your brain function at its very peak and it's best
when you feel the smoothest,
the longest,
the most often you can do that with supplementation better than you can without
supplementation.
This is from anecdotal evidence and my personal evidence,
what like my personal experience rather,
and it's also from research,
all the research available at [inaudible] dot com including our own double blind
placebo studies that we did on Alpha brain.
We did one showed positive results.
We're doing a much larger one now.
What we're trying to do it on it is just sell you the shit that we find that
works as far as strength and fitness equipment,
the strength and conditioning equipment we sell like kettle bells and battle
ropes and weight vest,
steel maces,
all these different things are great for functional strength.
No bullshit,
no gimmicks,
no fat loss.
Nonsense.
If we find it,
it's got to work before we sell it and we look into it very,
very thoroughly.
We also have a 100% money back guarantee on any of the supplements.
90 90 days,
30 pills,
the first bottle,
a hundred percent money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return the product.
We're trying to sell you the best shit we can find.
Go to o,
n n I t use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right.
You fucks Mad Flavor,
Aka and they also have to stay on a program where they mail you to stuff every
month.
Automatically.
The house.
Yes,
on the first tremendous.
You can't beat that and you get 20% off and to Rogan whatever in the box and get
the motherfucking 20% off.
They deliver it to your house.
You could put it on program.
You get your Alpha,
bring your stroop Jack.
You can rotate it because I talked to Mr. Rios.
You can rotate the stock we're in,
so whatever you need,
they'll send it to you the first of the month.
You have to sit there and go back on the fucking computer drive for 90 days.
Cox.
Yeah,
they get on a program has been very successful.
Tremendous.
Go there.
Get your freak on.
Joey Diaz is here.
Come Out Rogan
experience.
Try by day Joe Rogan podcast,
my night.
Boom.
Shut,
lock,
boom Joe.
We motherfucking Diaz.
What's up my brother violating state law.
You've got an electronic cigarette in the house.
What am I going to do?
I have a question for you by the,
uh,
while we're at it,
cause I always,
I always have questions for you but I forgot to talk to you.
About a month ago somebody posted the mushrooms,
the quadricep mushroom,
cordyceps,
shroom tech and they had like what this mushroom looks like in 10 years and how
it got fun guy.
And this is what it does to inside your system.
That's all bullshit.
It does inside your system,
like inside your body,
what it does and Shit.
Look,
there's a lot of mushrooms that people eat on a daily basis,
like fungus as a normal part of people's diets.
W W you know when you,
when you eat,
what if he should talk?
He mushrooms are eating a fungus right?
And something that's a fungus.
You know,
your,
your whole body is filled little growing organisms,
but no cordyceps mushrooms not going to grow inside your body and like make
roots,
create fucking plants.
They come his ass off Facebook.
They show like waters said mushrooms.
This was happened.
Was it a bunch of different kinds of cordyceps mushrooms to the,
the,
there's two different types in uh,
in um,
shroom tech,
sport,
two different types of courts,
subs,
mushrooms.
When you do look the shooting tech support,
it's not that you get hyped.
I don't get height.
No,
I just feel that the yet I'm like,
I look at the clock and like we'll usually I leave at this time when,
when I got one more.
Yeah.
You get an extra round or two.
Got One more.
Yeah,
no bullshit at me.
You know where it came from came from these high altitude herders.
They were like moving cattle around and they found that these,
these,
when these animals would eat these certain mushrooms,
they'd be noticeable,
noticeably more lively.
So they realize like it's probably something to do with oxygen production.
This is like,
I guess if you go to certain places of the world,
it makes sense that there are certain foods that would be good,
that grow in that to help you deal with certain aspects of the environment.
That's challenging.
You know,
like high altitude,
you know,
it's like you go to Denver,
it's fucking,
you go up the flight of stairs.
I was like,
whoa.
That's like whenever they have a UFC card and Denver,
I'm always like,
all right,
here we go.
Fucking.
They had Ben Rothwell and Mark Hunt Two dudes not exactly known to be
triathletes,
go fight in Denver.
And it was a crazy fight,
man.
I was just a ridiculous,
crazy white.
We're both guys almost died.
They don't both almost had heart attacks to fighting.
If 5,500 feet above sea level,
you weight 265 fucking pounds go to hell.
How much do you have to how long before it says,
it says six weeks to acclimate.
Yeah,
Walt.
They said,
but I don't think I talked to a guy who lived there who was a triathlete and he
told me that he moved there for his training.
Right.
That's,
yeah,
like the,
like a lot of those endurance athletes move there.
He was in boulder and he told me it takes three years,
three full years before your body's like,
like right.
The white how you are right now.
If you're in Burbank,
boom,
right now,
Joey Diaz,
you would have to to get to be this level of comfort with your breathing
environment and with the,
the oxygen level in the air.
It would take you approximately three years to get 100%,
but you get pretty close within the first five windows.
Fighters go to Dennis,
how long do they go?
Two weeks.
There's a lot of debate on that.
What they're thinking now is that what you should do is not train at altitude.
What they think now is that you should train at sea level but then sleep at
altitude.
So if that's the case that you don't have to go anywhere.
Like Bj Penn had one of those tents that he would set up in his house and when
he was,
we'd go to bed at night,
he would sleep in this oxygen tent and it was like a,
it's simulated,
uh,
being at high altitude.
So that's what guys are using now.
They're using these tents.
It was funny because Bj set it up and it goes,
it was really funny.
As he was setting it up,
he goes,
when I got to sleep in a tent,
someone's getting their ass kicked.
He's setting up this fucking plastic tent in his living room.
You know?
It's a wild,
I was just in Utah and Salt Lake City.
That also has elevation.
You don't remember.
You just go out and do this.
This BJ sleeping in a tent.
Back it up.
Set Joe.
He could see it.
Is that pat coming?
I got it.
I got it
as it.
Who is he?
I don't know.
He's just talking football player.
Oh yeah.
A lot of guys do this now.
They sleep and he's fucking tense.
I know when they play football in Denver,
that's murder.
When people come and visit,
they got a flight on Monday and they get to practice the whole week.
The NFL does.
You don't cause you to do because you got to do something just to acclimate.
You gotta ramp up for that.
Chet,
you can.
You should.
You should ramp up your,
your training and your cardio beforehand.
Anyway,
just to deal with the fact that you're going to like just,
some guys don't have to do anything.
They're just in such good shape.
They get up to Denver there,
they deal with it a little bit,
they feel it a little bit,
but they're in such good shape.
They could just push forward.
It's amazing when you walk around the city of boulder per se,
and you walk around,
you're there for six weeks and you've got acclimated and everything or whatever
they say and you start getting used to it and then you go skiing and that's what
you really find because that's a level on the,
on the mountains that it's just brutal.
It's just fucking brutal killing 11,000 feet and you get up there and here's the
fucking crazy thing.
A lot of people decide to eat up there and that's when you're in trouble.
Really.
Your body can't have that.
Your body can't handle no shit.
Little Wall up at uptown,
I'm talking to,
I pay 11,000 you could ski down it.
That's fine.
We skied and we get to the bottom and go up and you get your momentum and your
ski and you get,
it's when people stop up there and they hang out for an hour and they eat,
they got out the tubes,
sickness,
high altitude,
you know,
is a high altitude sickness.
It's a motherfucker.
It's like beating see sake.
Really.
It's like being seasick.
You just want to lay down and it makes sense man.
Yeah.
Cause uh,
living at 8,500 feet,
you like when you go up a flight of stairs,
like anytime you go up a flight of stairs,
you gotta go,
Ooh.
Like I've never,
I never go up a flight of stairs and take a big deep breath.
But in boulder only take a big deep breath.
And you can imagine that like if you go higher than that,
go like 11,000,
like 8,000 to 5,000.
There's a big difference.
So I gotta imagine 11,
it's like some next level,
next level shit.
And it's crazy because when you're up there for a while,
you're tired.
Like you don't have to do anything.
Just talk to people up there.
It just puts your body through something.
Cause the first time I moved to Colorado,
I didn't go to bolt.
I went to Aspen and all I felt like doing was sleeping.
And I would say 10.
I don't even sleep now at 50 right.
Paint.
I didn't fucking sleep.
We slept man for like three weeks.
All I could do is fucking sleep.
I couldn't take it no more.
Wow.
It was just that happy.
I passed out up there smoking pot.
The first time I took a big old bong hit picking me up off the fucking floor.
First Day in Aspen on a Sunday morning,
afternoon,
I went to some people's house over.
Uh,
it was Galina's street.
They had an apartment.
I went up there,
blah,
blah blah.
I want to do a bong.
Yeah,
I'm a tough guy.
Boom.
Bam.
Bumping the head.
Ice Cubes in your head.
Fucking tremendous.
We had a catch,
a fear factor executive.
Uh,
in New York we had a catcher because she passed out on the street,
stepped outside of a bar.
This is after September 11th.
It was the coolest time to be in New York,
man.
Everybody was so god damn friendly.
It was like less than a year since the attacks and we're filming make maybe a
year,
I don't know.
I want to say it's 2002 somewhere.
And so we're standing outside of this,
uh,
this bar and a,
I go,
who wants some of this?
Come on pussies.
Who wants some of this?
I pulled out a joint and a,
they got crazy.
They got Kinda it.
We'll do it.
We'll do it with you.
I'm like,
oh my goodness,
you guys are fucked.
Like they don't have any idea like nonsmokers have no,
I mean they might have smoked weed a little bit in college.
You don't know what the fuck you're getting into if no idea how crazy the suite
is.
Oh my goodness.
So she took one hit and she's standing there and then just see her eyes,
like slowly start to roll back and I see her body given and then we just rushed
in and Carter were like,
whoa.
And then we called the ambulance.
No,
you did.
Yeah.
It didn't know what was going on.
She had had a few health issues too,
so we're a little worried like something might be going on other than the weed,
you know.
So we,
we called her call an ambulance for,
but it's weird watching someone black out from weed.
You know,
I told that story about that one person in college that uh,
she took one hit of a joint or a bong or whatever it was.
She stood up and just start running as fast as she could into the bathroom and
trips over the bathtub and smashes her head into the wall.
And she had no idea why.
She just said,
she said to her body just took over and she couldn't,
she didn't know what she blacked out and she just started running.
That should be the commercial.
We not for everybody.
Not Anymore.
Nothing's for everybody,
but anymore.
Nothing's for everybody.
Including,
you know,
fucking cats.
Yeah,
I know.
Ladies are allergic to chickens.
She's like,
I love chickens,
but I'm allergic to them.
What the fuck are you talking about?
You're allergic chickens.
How are you allergic to chickens?
How's that?
Even happen.
Can even pick up a chicken show.
I was a kid.
I was allergic to dogs like a motherfuck.
I mean really doctor,
I had to go to a doctor if I had contact with a dog,
but you know,
like that now over the years I just kept playing with them.
I couldn't live like that.
I couldn't live like that no more.
That's when she was doing horrible way to live.
If I went to some of these houses,
child,
they had a collie or something.
And when you were kids like,
yeah,
I couldn't fucking touch this college.
You know when you were a kid and somebody got a colleague,
that's it.
It's lastly motherfucker.
That's as good as it gets.
And My godmother had a collie and my mom go,
you can't go in the house.
I got a fucking going out house.
I got to see him.
They called him last.
He and I would hug him and an hour later my eyes would be like fluff.
And I got punched in the face.
Both of them.
Wow.
And they make me wash my hands.
After an hour,
they go to the hospital,
they put some whatever and I am and they telling me not to fuck with a dog.
So I pay eight times.
I should have brought dogs with my fucking phone and my side.
When I was a kid from getting bit,
I got bit in the face,
I got bit in the leg,
I got,
I kept getting bit.
Goldman pinches,
kept biting me.
German shepherds,
dogs bite kids because kids are grabbed their face.
No,
I never harassed my fear.
I had such a fear of that.
And then,
uh,
one time I'm like Spanish Harlem and the guy used to walk past me every day in
the summer and he had two dogs and would say,
don't share a lot of my dogs,
you know,
don't talk to my dog.
And we go,
okay.
Cause I was trying to work over the fear.
I knew that somebody said you got to play with them.
If not,
they're gonna keep biting it.
And probably after a summer,
one day,
I didn't say hello to the dogs.
The dogs are both buying.
The female came back and bit me in the fucking leg.
She was saying,
hello.
I talked to him.
So this is not time.
Like I haven't been scared of dogs.
I know at all.
What are some people that have bad dogs though?
There's some people that just have pet dogs.
They don't,
they didn't take care of their dog.
They raise a shitty dog and the dog's dangerous.
That's a fact.
Listen,
man,
uh,
dogs just,
you know,
they don't know.
They don't fucking know.
I don't fucking know.
You know,
you can't.
Every day we hear about a dog attack or some shit,
you don't fucking,
well,
it's weird.
We're living
with animals.
We've got this weird animal that we allowed to live with us.
And you know,
it protects you,
which means what protects you means it protects you from other people.
I mean,
one of the last time you heard about a dog protecting someone from an animal,
it's pretty rare,
right?
They're protecting you from other people.
And so you've got a dog that's trained to by people,
which is very strange animals that you have around you that are essentially like
trained weapons trained to go after people like when people have those attacks.
Shepherds remember when George Foreman George Foreman fought Muhammad Ali.
He brought his German shepherd to Zaire and it was this big deal because the
black people that lived there,
the ad,
the actual Africans that live there fucking hated German shepherds because
German shepherds of the dogs and the cops had got upset.
So they saw George Foreman as like the enemy and Muhammad Ali played on that
like a motherfucker.
He played on that like a motherfucker and realized that George had fucked up by
bringing this German shepherd with them to Africa and that's where the Ali boom,
ba,
ba boom,
ba.
A lot of that had to do with
the fight in Africa.
Just him.
Yeah,
in the Philippines,
he fought Joe Frazier,
Frazier in Manila,
the Thrilla in Manila.
That's the place where he pointed the gun at them from the bottom.
Joe's Fraser's on his balcony and shit getting decided.
Mohammad Ali.
He said,
Joe Frazier,
and he pointed like,
I started this pistol at him.
Did he really?
Yeah,
it's crazy.
You know,
Molly was crazy in a funny way.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
he was crazy.
In a funny way.
What was that year was,
we know that video I showed you a James Brown the first time I came in your
pocket.
That's where the video was taken because it was George Foreman.
It gets Muhammad Ali.
Don King said,
wait a second,
I ain't stealing enough on this fight.
I might as well get a musical performance.
Get a bunch of motherfuckers out here steal from them too.
And I just robbed a bunch of black people all at once.
Right,
right.
So he robbed.
He got the spinners.
He got,
uh,
he got James Brown.
He got all of these black bands to go to fucking Zaire and perform as a music
festivals.
Sally at Cruise,
he got to find the all stars.
He got,
uh,
who,
he got like just all these black bands and what happened?
He probably just stiffed me.
Shit.
He probably just stepped them through.
He's like,
I didn't make enough money,
then they're going to cancel that fight.
We weren't thinking something
was wrong with that fight.
I don't know.
Look it up.
Something happened.
It was going to get pushed back.
Oh really?
He had the music already set up.
It's very interesting that that uh,
they made a movie about it called sole power and that's a,
sorry,
who's that guy that says lovely day?
Lovely day bill withers.
I don't remember.
Yeah,
Bill withers is in that,
uh,
in that movie.
Fucking tremendous.
That was a,
they made a documentary about that fight too,
right when we were kings.
Yeah.
Watch though.
Watch like pieces of it.
I never watched the whole thing.
Good.
Not Bad.
You know,
as much as you could watch those.
But there's a great picture of Muhammad Ali were bill with his,
you know,
he got that sings all those great love songs.
You don't,
I'm telling him about bill withers and he's got his shirt off in Africa.
He the fucking steak and eggs and Mohammad Ali's just dropping knowledge,
talking,
you know,
about the fight and Bill Williams is next to him.
And he won't look up.
He's just eating this fucking steak.
It's so yummy for your tummy.
He won't look no shirt on.
Bill with withers fucking tremendous.
That was the one that don king's first fights.
Was it really?
Yeah,
it's apparently one of his first ventures as according to Wikipedia as a
professional boxing promoter.
And he managed to get Ali and foreman to sign separate contracts saying they
would fight for him if he could get a $5 million purse.
So,
and then he took that and then he went to this other company,
had to go to a,
an outside country for the event because he didn't have the money.
So a xy years president ready for this name.
Mobutu Sese Seko uh,
asked if the,
the fight could be held in his country and eager for the publicity from such a
high profile event,
blah,
blah.
And uh,
they put together a bunch of different investment.
Um,
different companies invested,
some Panamanian Investment Company,
British company,
a bunch of different companies and they all coughed up the cash and threw it
through it together.
What a fucking fight.
That was too.
That was Jesus Christ.
What a fucking fight that was.
That was one of them.
I'm Mohammad Ali's greatest performances ever because nobody thought he was
gonna win.
Nobody.
People don't understand what [inaudible] 72 brothers 74 wow.
People don't realize what a mother Fucker,
George Foreman was back then.
He was a motherfucker.
You hit hard and he was like a silent Ali,
like you didn't do a lot of talking,
but he was just subbed to the Max who was so dangerous when he fought Joe
Frazier and picked him up with a punch.
He hit Joe Frazier so hard.
He went up into the air.
He was just a different thing.
You know?
Joe Frazier was no walk in the park.
He fucking,
only three dudes put some scary fucking heavy weights.
I think Joe Frazier is a really scary guy with that fucking left.
Okay.
Is it hits you like a fucking bomb?
Yeah.
He had,
it was like a moving oak.
Yeah.
He was tremendous.
He could die.
It's hard to do that,
like to just come up like that by,
by,
by Bam.
He would throw his whole body,
his whole body.
I never see
that hooked.
Did he knocked Muhammad Ali Down with oh one picture.
Perfect Punch.
He would just swing into that.
Right?
Even if he knew it was coming.
Yeah.
Even if even the ones you show him ducking light that once you show him taking
that little step back,
a little crotch,
whatever,
that's all he would do.
That shell
to that Philly shell where you put like one hand up,
one hand down and bobbing and weaving and coming in and weapon shots.
Joe Frazier was a motherfucker.
Sad wasn't we used to go to Philly.
We used to drive passage.
Jim,
I'm away from the APP.
What?
That neighbor,
he lived at his gym before he died.
Yeah,
he went broke and the end,
look,
the amount of money that these guys make for the time,
they're talking about $5 million persons for Ali informant for the time.
If you have $5 million back then that is a lot of goddamn money.
But guess what?
You live like you've got $5 million,
so you're buying fucking Cadillacs and paying for this and paying for that and
meals here and jets there and next thing you know,
$5 million doesn't even make it to the 80s and you know the
brothers is showing up at the door.
But my young last motherfucking cousin,
yeah,
listen man,
we got to venture and this mother fucker can't go wrong.
White neighborhood first year going to make 30% of your investments.
Second year,
60% on,
you know that's Matt and it just hit you with some crazy speech.
How many of those do you ever had to deal with?
Three.
Oh,
you got them all the time.
How to deal with one recently movies,
TV shows,
you get them constantly.
Ear beatings.
I even come,
he said,
man,
I'm not a movie producer.
All you have to do
is give us a check and we'll do the whole,
you don't have to do anything.
You don't have to worry about it.
Yes I do.
I have to worry about it.
No,
no,
no.
You don't have to worry about it.
No,
no.
I do have to worry about it.
If I give you money,
I'm going to worry about it.
Get out of here where your crazy idea does the reason why they have banks.
Okay,
go to the bank.
If you have a really good idea and you have credit,
go to the fucking bank.
If you don't have credit,
I got to assume somewhere along the line you've already made some poor fucking
choices.
I don't want to be involved in that.
People have this,
everybody has this idea that they,
they're gonna figure out how to circumvent this time honored system of
Hollywood.
And we're going to get to Joe Diaz.
If I can get to Cho Diaz.
I know Judy has been killing it on the road.
If he can give me just $2,000 and I could start this film.
You Know Quentin Tarantino does his barn.
Ryan and Kevin Smith made clerks and man,
man,
man.
And they just think that all they need is a couple grand from Joey Diaz,
Joe,
Joe.
You can't go wrong.
Okay?
Nobody makes movies.
Okay,
join.
They just don't want me in.
They don't want me and Joey take don't want me and Joey d as they want to keep
me on the outside.
No,
you get them for your time.
It's not even that you get them for money.
It's you get them for your time.
Yeah.
Look at you when you're living through you.
You're busy.
Yeah,
you're swamp.
There's no more no more.
I keep telling people that and they get mad at me.
They don't understand.
When you have children,
there's no schedule.
I can't count on my schedule,
Bro.
At 10 20 she wouldn't get off my fucking lap watching one,
two,
three videos on youtube at 10 30 I went to pick her up like,
let's go with what?
What will you fucking talking about?
Like I'll be back in a couple of hours.
They didn't know what the fuck that means.
You don't have no fucking idea what it is to,
and I went to get to go into the room at nine 30 I get out of it.
I was going to get out of there early.
That little bitch opened the gate.
I heard those stomping and like this.
There's no argument.
She just puts her hands up,
got to pick her up,
got to put youtube on.
I got to sit there with a one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
you know,
and then she again,
Daddy.
Okay,
well the problem with people asking you to do things too is that you kind of do
this shit for yourself.
Okay?
The way to do it is not to go through other people and ask people to pick you up
and help you.
That's not how it works.
It doesn't work that way and pay.
Everybody thinks you're gonna figure out some fucking choke shortcut cause they
know you or they know this guy or that guy.
This.
There's no shortcuts in creating something.
Just figure it out.
Bitch.
I love standup because there's one part of me that doesn't need anybody.
Are these a notebook right here?
This is my tools for standard and a person,
but go,
go to Bob's fucking coffee house on North Hollywood and do three minutes.
You know me,
I don't give a fuck.
When you,
we talked about having a band that somebody came on here and said that it was
the toughest thing in the world for a band to stay together.
You got four people personalities,
you know,
you get these people that come to you and I,
and I was breaking it down from another planet.
They don't say,
hey Joe,
how you doing?
My name is this,
read my script for you.
Like it.
Yeah,
we're going to get $8 million.
And then you go,
okay,
when you get it,
call me.
I really liked the script.
Something you're interested in,
whatever,
three days,
all of a sudden you do get a call in the ELA and they say,
hey,
we're making a movie,
but guess what?
We didn't get $2 million.
We've got $200,000 so instead of you getting 10,000 a week,
you're going to get a hundred a day and it's going to be a hit.
We're going to make it happen.
Nine out of 10 they run out of money for marketing and editing and the whole
fucking thing.
So your movie ends up in Youtube.
They don't have a legit schedule,
so you have to work Saturdays and fucking Sundays.
You know those people that are involved in those low rent movies,
they're a fucking nightmare and it's their dream and I get,
it's your dream,
but don't include me in this fucking thing because you want me to do everything
cheap on my end.
All the hours and it's your fucking dream.
If it's that much of your dream,
and do me a favor,
if forget got the 200 gs,
we're getting another 300 gs and make this fucking work.
Well,
not only that,
you can find other actors out there that will do it for cheap.
There's people that are out there that just want to ask sort of like a comic
would go to an open mic night.
There's certain actors that just want to do something to put it on a real go
find them.
There's a lot of talented people out there that are not working as far as like
acting goes.
There's a lot of fucking people that can do it.
There's a lot of times of gay people.
It's just the,
I just have a problem.
People like asking you to help them do it.
Like I get it from comics all the time too.
Just looking for a break.
What are you talking about?
This you're not,
you're not going to get a break from another comic.
The way you get breaks is by going on stage and being funny.
Like go to an open mic night.
Be Funny.
The club will say,
Hey Joey Diaz your fucking funny.
We would like you to come here more often.
The audience really enjoyed you.
Next thing you know,
some manager says,
you know what Joey Diaz,
you're really funny.
We would like to,
uh,
think about taking you on as a client.
That's how it works.
Like a comic coming along.
It's not going to make you funnier.
And then the people that do that,
they always have a distorted perception of how good they are already.
You know those,
those kids that are asking for a break,
the kids that want you to help him,
hey man,
I just need a break.
If I could do a guest set for you.
It really helped me like this.
Not you don't,
you don't go to the Doug Stan hope show and asked for a fucking guests.
All our Doug,
we'll probably put you up,
Doug Pyrite do 15 and started to go up front.
Doug will push Apokyn,
open micro and his first time on stage he'll do that in front of like a crowd in
Norway or something.
But that Stan Hope,
you know,
uh,
it's not normal.
You have to do you.
I,
it's,
it's amazing what people,
you know,
we weren't like that.
Thank God.
We knew that this took work and heart.
We knew that this wasn't going to happen in one night.
I was old enough already when I started.
I was long in the tooth already that I knew this was just not going to,
you know,
you just didn't walk on stage and things happen and people come here and they
called desperadoes where they just do,
don't come up to you for a guest and you got to ask him,
what is this going to do for you?
Right.
I was just going to fucking change your life.
It's like I've never been too much of a hanger rider.
I don't believe in that.
I never believed in that shit.
You know?
I believe in doing the spot.
If I go to the comedy store,
it's because I'm doing the fucking spot.
If I don't go to,
I don't go to the Improv and my name isn't on that list.
The hangout.
There's no for me,
there's no,
no,
no.
Because if you come up to Joe Rogan,
red band or Jamie and go,
Hi Jamie,
my name is Joey Diaz.
I'm a fucking cop.
I'm a funny comment.
Jamie's going to say,
are you going up tonight because we all want to watch it.
I love to laugh,
right?
You're funny.
Let's go.
No,
I'm just here hanging out.
You ain't that fucking funny.
If you're not on the list,
you ain't that fucking fun or they don't know about you yet.
There's a possibility that certain people that go to the Improv,
that's it,
and they'll tell you,
dog,
you've got a network.
What network?
Your network on a stage.
I net work on stage when they laughed when I walk off.
That's networking.
Not only that,
when you're a comic,
you're sort of like a fruit or a vegetable.
In that year,
you're growing and then you're going to one day you're going to be ripe and when
you're gonna be
right,
everyone's going to know about it and people find out about you.
If people found out about everybody,
they found out about you,
they found out about Hinchcliffe.
They find out about everything.
Yearbook,
Dunkin,
you what happened?
Like what's happening in China right now?
What's happening in China?
I was packing them in,
Oh yeah.
Every night.
And he goes,
I can't believe it was white people and UFC fans.
I in China,
they're coming from money out.
Yeah.
Okay.
They're not big rooms.
There are 120 seat and you can see this is like coffee shops,
right?
But where on the Internet,
this shit is worldwide.
Worldwide.
Yeah.
This is,
we can't believe it that there's fucking people walking around here going,
we came to see you from Macau.
I can't believe it took people so long to figure it out or he's a fucking
genius.
He's a great comic.
It's,
uh,
it's just amazing that people have misled.
They think they're shortcuts.
We got here.
What was the shortcut?
If you get on the tonight show,
right?
That's it.
How many people have gone to the tonight show and I'm not great success.
No one cares.
A lot of peat now it doesn't.
No,
but back in the day it meant something big.
You know,
Steven Wright days,
you get on Letterman.
That's it,
man.
You're fucking Roseanne Barr,
who you had on the show recently.
You know who,
who's a perfect example of a guy who paid his dues and who's just out there
silently murdering Ian motherfucking Edwards.
Fucking about words is killing people.
Don't know.
Ian Edwards is one of the
country,
one of the very best,
like not,
not like top 30.
He's like top 20.
Maybe even top 15.
He's a murderer.
Dude.
He killed me the other night at the Improv.
Killed me.
He's very subtle,
subtle,
and Suffolk.
Perth jokes are perfect.
The perfect structure.
It's like he's got a perfect inflection.
So he's slick and Hillel like loose and relaxed.
Sunstone like,
where's he going with this?
And he comes back with a left hook.
Lastly though,
late Joe Frazier,
he's a killer dude and he's so,
I liked his voice because he's his boy skills.
That's what I like about.
And that's his strength is how small he is.
He's got a new,
um,
uh,
yeah,
it's on,
it's on Conan O'brien's record label.
It's the first one.
It's called 100%.
Halfassed it's really funny,
man.
He's fucking really good right now.
I've known Ian since the nineties.
Dude,
I knew Ian in the early,
I think I knew him in 1990.
So think about value for years.
I've known that dude for 2023 I know,
I knew him when I lived in New York and that was like,
I think I moved to New York in [inaudible] 91 so I knew him from then one of
this week.
Great Guy.
Always been a great guy.
I always been a great guy.
Like can't,
can't say enough good shit about that dude.
And he's a Vegan.
I don't even give a fuck.
He is.
Yeah,
he's a vegetarian.
It had very,
very least a vegetarian dude's awesome.
So I got to shit in a cup on Friday.
So they said,
well three of these.
What a segue.
By the way,
I've done that.
Shouldn't have come yet.
Three different little kind of tests.
You have to put pieces of poop in three different ones.
What's it that for?
It's disgusting.
Why would I want to shit somebody at a fucking,
that's disgusting.
What did they testing it for it?
Cause they tested me for a tape.
Worms come from bad Sushi.
No,
everything.
I'm going in for the 50 and then the fourth I got to drink a potion for a day
and veggies,
water,
water there.
Monday or 6:00 AM I go to Wilshire to see the Sinai,
that gimme anesthesiologist.
They put a camera up my ass hole that make sure there's nothing,
and then they pull it out.
And then you have to have,
so you have to fart once.
Once you fly,
you're good to go.
They let you go.
Have you ever had a dog that had worms?
Yes.
Yeah.
Have you ever seen it and their poop?
Yes.
White things moving around thing ever.
Man,
I had a dog.
She had uh,
she had worms and when she would poop you would like see it out of her ass.
Like it was on the edge of our little booty hole.
That'd be like little worms,
like twisting and tweaking around and they fall off.
It was disgusting.
She had to get,
uh,
some anti warm medication and kill everything that was inside of her.
Yeah.
I thought my current dog had it because every time she shits she wipes her ass
and after she shits,
he just like rubs her butt on the grass and then it takes off.
And I'm like,
oh,
that means she has worms.
But she's,
sometimes it's just the itchy,
but yeah.
Does it seem,
does your budget sometimes once a dog figures out,
they could rub their ass on the carpet.
That's gotta be pretty God dynamic.
They get those toes up in the air,
you know,
that move,
like they're doing yoga and then they just started fucking not,
but along with the little toes he's up.
Does your cat just nonstop puke all the time and cat is taken to this new habit
of shitting and weird rooms in the house.
Yeah,
it's disgusting.
Like,
Oh yeah,
she's 18 years old.
She's really,
she got,
they get dementia too.
She doesn't know what's going on.
I should mention miles in the middle of the night,
in the middle of the night.
She knows.
Know where she is.
She just says,
and you come out and you like think she's dying.
Like why?
She's like,
well you're like,
hey fuck head.
Don't be waking me up.
Waking me up like you're screaming and yelling the middle to
this sweet,
sweet cat.
She's very needy men.
Very needy.
Like where I want to get some work done,
sit down in my office.
Sometimes I have to put her out in the hallway cause she'll just keep hopping in
my lap.
I'm like,
listen bitch,
I got to work.
But she looks at you like you're,
you're free massages.
No did.
She doesn't like anybody else in my house either because she doesn't like my
little kids.
You know?
And she remembers my stepdaughter is a little kid too,
so like she's no little kids.
Like,
she's like,
yeah,
they'll fuck out everybody out,
out everybody out.
She doesn't want to have nothing to do with kids.
So like she just runs away from everybody in the house but me.
So when I'm not home,
the pitches hides,
she's hot.
She's like,
where is this bitch?
Like if I'm,
if I'm on the road for like five days,
she's like,
what the fuck is going on here?
Where is this asshole?
So as soon as I come home,
lets me
follow me around and circles.
I have a black gay love.
I can't,
what do you have fucking,
I've had her since she was a baby.
She was a little tiny kid and I got it from my sister.
My sister had a cat and the cat got fucked by some wildcat.
They lived in,
uh,
the,
outside of Boston suburbs,
like Pr,
you call it the suburbs,
but it's pretty rural.
Like they had coyotes and shit and they had raccoons would tear apart their
trash and they'd wildcats.
A lot of wild cats like feral cats are pretty common.
Um,
but there were people's pets,
you know,
there were wild but they weren't,
they weren't like dangerous wild cats like farm cats.
They were just,
people let their cats out.
The cats would go run around.
Fucking so were,
it was old school.
Cat gave birth in the middle of the kitchen.
They put it in the box,
shut out some kittens and she had all these kittens.
I took one of them and that's Bas.
If she is 18 years later,
she's like,
she's fine.
Like I think Mrs Rogan probably wanted her dead a while ago.
Shit in various spots in the house.
But that kind of going nowhere.
Mine's doing that.
Asa Mitzi shore.
That cat died.
She came to the comedy store the other day if she did or my cat.
Yeah.
I guess she just came in and she stayed in the car.
But,
uh,
yeah,
she was alive and it seemed like she was good enough to get it on a car and
stuff.
I didn't say it,
but my friend Justin for young comics place,
she's just,
just,
if you find out that she's going to be there and just go there to stare at her.
Yeah.
Cool.
Little stare at one of the most important figures in the history of comedy.
Draw her.
Just go look at her.
Just so you could say,
I saw Mitzi Mitzi shore in real life.
You should do that because she ain't gonna be here forever.
That,
that ladies,
one of the most important figures ever in comedy.
If it wasn't for her,
I would have never without a doubt,
never been the same comedian.
I wouldn't be at this table.
I would have been gone by now.
I would never been the same.
She that,
that lady,
uh,
she threw me into the fire trial by fire every time there's anybody,
anybody good at the comedy store?
Martin Lawrence,
when he was in his prime doing movies,
guess who's going on after Martin Lawrence right here.
A kid go up there to eat a fat play to dicks and learn how to do standup.
We'll be behind Paul Mooney for a year
at midnight.
The really till I met my wife,
I said a lot
and give you all three is fucking proxy,
but destroying my fucking breaking me down.
I mean that's how I got back up.
By doing blow,
I would leave dead depressed.
I'm going to have to do a fucking rock just to get back.
All right,
I got another hope.
I got them on and I looked at who am I following?
Even if it wasn't a j,
whatever was in front of the HTA would cancel an aga would be if it was a
fucking nightmare.
Guys,
it was a mall.
Was Sue squeaky clean,
squeaky.
God Damn Polaris.
Hilarious,
beautiful timing.
It was hard to go on out.
Oh,
it was like driving to Jujitsu.
You're going to die.
Why am I even doing this shit?
Why the fuck am I going here?
I'm just going to be on bottom and stuck all fucking day.
I'm going to do debt.
By the way.
I got to ask you a question with y'all animals.
I know you don't watch it,
but you gotta watch this shit cause it's going to affect you.
I watched that.
A real sports with buffer.
Bruce Buffer,
and you see the story before that you see about the horses,
how they juice it.
If you think Vandelay and chair with juice to the fucking nine,
what they'd do.
You know how many horses died at aqua duck race trail alone in January?
This she just from steroids,
26 well that's what
all those still like echo poise.
Remember equipoise bodybuilders would take that is a horse stair equity.
It's like whore equine
about Horace Mann with people doing this year.
Right?
I didn't know that.
Steroids,
my brother look it up.
That'd be on like quantics Equinix that give them Decca,
the Roblin for Germans that give her,
yeah,
about 26 horses on one month.
Four weeks divided by 26 that's a lot of,
and then that I watching this and I don't have to go to the track.
I had to go to the Santa Anita that Saturday for a kid's thing.
They paint your face in the middle and they think the kids on horses.
I was looking forward to him like,
you know what?
I ain't going.
I told my wife and my,
I'm boycotting that shit.
I sat and she gets,
Joey,
you've got to,
you already made commitments
to kids.
I went up there,
third race,
fucking horse died fucking noise back on the track and shit.
The heart attack.
Did it fall down?
They just bro,
they just dead dying on the track.
They getting hot.
They've just juicing them to the gills.
Gills brow.
Speaking of juice to the gills,
pull up that video that I put on my Twitter page yesterday about the strong man
guy breaking his back.
See that he didn't break his back.
Apparently he's okay.
What apparently is okay?
He,
his body failed in the middle of lifting what they call an atlas stone.
An atlas stone is like a,
a globe,
like a giant glow,
but it's a rock and it weighs like 300 plus pounds.
And this guy's hoisting this rock up onto these pedestals and he's in the middle
of hoisting this rock up on the pedestal.
And I guess he blacked out from the strain.
I guess he was straining so hard.
That was like,
he was getting choked because like,
he didn't have any oxygen.
His brains,
it's just
boom,
he falls down and it's fucking huge.
Boulder lands.
I'm looking at this dude,
check this out.
Look at the size of this fucking boulders.
She's hoisting it up.
It's trying to get it up there.
Call fucking nine one one right now.
Why is that funny?
Why you laughing?
Cause I,
I won't watch the video,
but I was watching show
we should have been a Joey the whole time.
Oh my God.
It's that crazy.
The guys.
Okay,
the guys.
Okay.
Um,
everybody thought that he broke his back and that was the title of the video.
But apparently what happened was he just blacked out and really,
um,
had nothing but cuts and bruises.
Um,
even went on to finish the event,
which is crazy,
you know,
I don't know how the fuck the guy did it.
Maybe 300 plus whatever the fuck it is.
Pound huge thing landed on his body.
I don't know how the hell you survived that.
Can I ask you some steroids questions?
Sure.
Is Deka still relevant?
Do people still do all these steroids I talked about from the 80s,
like Anna Var and winstrol lists.
I'm sure if you're in bodybuilder circles,
you know it's not for MMA fighters to,
and when Emma vape MMA,
MMA fighters get popped for more than anything is testosterone.
Just because you can get regular testosterone now.
So easy.
There's so many people that are getting testosterone replacement therapy
prescriptions.
They'll like,
it's Kinda a lot behind you.
There's something to the sentence.
The last three is a more,
I probably more,
probably more chiropractice fucking making a killer.
Chiropractice they're the ones who do it the most.
They what prescribed test should do is,
what they do is they get a doctor in house.
You get some slub like a medical marijuana doctor.
He's retired,
his wife at the lottery.
You ever go to a medical marijuana doctor?
They're all over 60.
I wouldn't fit in grade one.
The bladder pill.
They don't give a fuck.
They've already been sued 80 times.
When I give a fuck,
you're not going to get sued for this shit.
Like that one guy that gives us that,
we'd prescriptions that has that uh,
office in Hollywood and he's the best.
He's the best.
He's the one that shows up with you and fights the court and tells him to suck
his dick.
I know he died and he went to jail.
He went to jail,
got lost his practice and went to jail in the 90s.
He was one of the first adopters.
But uh,
that,
you know,
what were you talking about?
Oh,
the chiropracticy
I brought it.
I didn't smoke,
but I did eat a half a cookie.
I hear him.
Don't get me wrong.
I did eat a little half.
I'm a fan.
So,
uh,
what you do is your partner up with a doctor.
You put her in the office,
you go upstairs,
you draw blood,
you come downstairs a week later,
you're low on testosterone.
Yeah.
You need a real doctor.
Do that because you need to get all your,
if you're going to fuck around like that,
you got to get all your,
your levels measured.
Your thyroid level measured your IGF.
I mean they're real duck,
this Joe and they know what they're doing.
Yeah.
They send you to,
they do all the paperwork and you go upstairs with the tasks and then they read
it to you.
They prescribed the blockers.
They prescribe everything all at once.
It's just you're working,
you're working very closely with the chiropractor and the chiropractor is not
some guy who walks around with sandals.
Right.
This guy is six foot six 292 pounds.
Fucking 90% yeah.
If I show you this chiropractor,
you're going to go,
oh yeah.
That's the man,
mother fucker.
Chiropractice that's a very controversial science if you want to call it a
science practice,
you know,
some people believe in wholeheartedly.
Some people think it's total horse shit.
Have you sat with them for awhile,
they'll sell it to you.
I got a good car.
I have a good,
I have a good financial Carol,
but he has a bunch of things in his office that I also like.
He has like a really good massage therapist.
He works on stretching with people.
It was like he's big on posture.
Like a lot of things that I know about posture come from him.
Like he explains it and like some no bullshit terms and he,
he also explains like,
like your whole like when people stand,
this is what's wrong with slumping.
I always thought slumping just looks sloppy and he goes,
no,
it's putting undue pressure on certain areas is our spine.
Your spine,
when you sit up straight and you're standing up straight,
your spine supports itself in a straight line,
but anytime you move head forward,
you're putting all this pressure,
like an uneven point,
like in the middle of your back you bought essentially we're supposed to be
like,
dogs are supposed to be walking on all fours.
You know,
there's a reason why it chimps.
Most chimps walk on all fours.
It's like,
and they don't have backaches.
It's like it's a better way of moving when human beings start standing up.
Apparently the flaws in the design of the back began to surface like we're not
done yet.
Like w eventually the body as it stands right now with this back issues that
most people have from picking things up,
most likely the body's going to evolve over the course of the next million years
or so and it probably be a much stronger version of a back in the future.
Now the kettle bell training has helped you back.
Oh yeah,
for sure is it says,
it basically says about people's backs and when you start kettlebell training,
you're back becomes,
they use this word resilient.
Yeah,
well the,
you get muscle all the,
the whole look,
if you feel someone's back,
if you go and like feel the actual back muscles themselves,
if you have more stronger back muscles supporting your spine,
it just makes sense.
If you practice proper posture and you have more muscle and stronger muscles
supporting the core of your body,
then you can resist movement.
An unexpected movement like say like in Jujitsu class or something like that.
If like you get yanked to side back and forth cause stronger,
your core is,
the more you're protected from that.
You know like,
like if you wrote with a guy who's got a really strong core like judo guys
specifically,
you can't move those fuckers around man.
Their core is so God damn strong.
So if you're trying to like lean against their core,
compress their core to like either flipped him over or to sweep them their
chorus.
So God damn strong.
It's like their pillar,
the what connects their body together.
It's just check it through that fucking thing.
Wrestlers,
same thing,
especially Greco Roman guys,
their upper body in their course,
so fucking strong from throwing bodies around all the time and that's sort of
what kettlebells mimic.
Just throwing things,
picking things up,
hoisting things with momentum,
all of that stuff.
That all builds core.
That all builds what everybody likes to call core.
But people do sit ups and leg lifts and Shit.
Get the fuck out of here with that.
You don't need that.
He needed heavy kettle bell swing.
Those mother fuckers impress him and do windmills.
That's where you get strong core weight.
Lowe's,
Dwight,
Dwayne Wade though,
boy Cruz to reps work increased the work.
Okay.
The more you do five you gave me,
you listen,
you can do 45 pounds for an hour or you can do 55 pounds for 40 minutes.
What it's all in,
how much you put in versus how much you get out.
But as far as for health benefits,
when you go heavy,
the problem is you risk injuries.
When you go like 55 pounds,
70 pounds,
90 pounds.
Once she gets that gets a little squirrely because your hoist and a lot of God
damn weight and you're carrying it and all these fibers and tissues,
you straining when you're doing like 55 pounds or 45 pounds,
it's not that much weight.
So you can get in a lot of reps and you get exhausted.
Like
that's what I do.
I get to the point where at the end of my forms,
stocks,
what's my form starts to stop.
I stopped out at 14 uh,
at like I do,
I try to do 10 sets of swings.
Infinitive Lee,
you know,
times 12 sometimes I'll do nine and I rest a minute.
I'm going a minute time.
Then I do another 1416 that I rest a minute,
another 1215 I go with my body,
right.
Once I get that,
once I do 10 of those 40 fives I do just single ones and I do 15 of those like
seven one and I switched it to eight and the other and vice versa.
Still with a minute,
but the time I get to the 14th one I could feel my form and starting to fade.
That's when it's sold.
I pick up the two 35 and I walk around the block like I can't take it no more.
I'm a farmer workout.
That's good for my posture.
That's
it.
That's great workout.
Listen,
I read,
I read it cause tanks to be,
I hang out with you.
I have a friend who has a coach and he goes,
the thing about kettle was the forgot that's 50 the less is the better,
but go with your body.
It tells you.
So they started a program at his place now five days a week,
kettlebells,
20 minutes a day,
you guaranteed 10 pounds in one month to lose certain die and they'd go there.
Certainly I just haven't been able to go cause I have it on the road Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
but I'm home the next three weeks and I'm going to work on it.
I'm going to go in there.
You can either go at night or in the morning,
20 minutes.
It's just,
it's great work,
great work for your body.
When you,
when you do it,
it's a combines.
All the benefits that you get from lifting weights with all the benefits that
you get from doing cardio.
You can get it all together in one movie.
It just,
you're forcing your body and do shit.
And if you do the workout that you're talking about right there,
that's a good word.
It's a very good workout.
And then I like how you're ending with the farmer's walks.
I opened up at the farmer's walk.
That's a good way to Warren.
I am with the farmer's walk.
I walk,
I get loose by put them down.
I arrested him and pick them up and just walk to as much as I can.
Sometimes I make it to Burbank Boulevard.
Oh really?
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Why not?
It's 10 o'clock at night.
I'm not doing nothing.
Why not?
If somebody gives a mug and I liked doing them,
I brought in the mornings.
I parked my car in front of my house,
go on my truck.
I got to kettlebells and my trunk got to boxing gloves,
I Shin guides.
I got a yoga mat.
That's awesome because sometimes I'll go to fucking north Hollywood park.
That's why I think I got,
I killed my meniscus.
Was that North Hollywood?
Because I had walked that thing and then do the kettlebells and they got that
one hot corner over there.
That's always 150 degrees.
I don't know what it is about Hollywood park that it's beautiful to walk is
beautiful,
but there's a dip with a son.
Even at night it's shines.
Even at night the sun shines that and it is fucking 140 in that corner.
But yeah,
I carry,
I liked it.
I liked to do the kettlebells outside.
When I do them inside,
I get anxiety.
I get hot.
I can't breathe.
I do on my side under the sun.
I blast him out like from nine 15 to 10 o'clock I'm done for the day though.
My body's burning shit all day.
You know what I just got from my kettlebells,
but a bowling ball carry on bag for an airplane because you can carry 50 pounds.
You take 50 pounds with you and check it.
So that checked his fucking cannon ball.
I throw it in there.
I'm the TSA is going to shit their pants.
They tried to pick up this little bag.
It's that big.
It weighs 50 pounds.
A great fucking idea,
man.
Check it it.
Just check it and they get mad at you.
But whatever.
I bring a 35 55 I'll bring her 35 35 is good.
Look that Keith Weber Kettle Bell Cardio workout that they saw it on it,
35 pounds,
you'd do it.
It's a tremendous workout and just you just keep going.
He just keeps going just over and over again.
All in the beginning.
First couple of minutes,
it's kind of easy,
but then you get five minutes in,
six minutes and you're like,
oh shit.
And you realize you've got to do this for 40 fucking minutes.
Holy
things.
You think it would be easier?
Clean press with 35 pounds.
It's nothing,
right?
Not when you're exhausted,
when you're exhausted,
when you keep telling your legs are on fire the next day,
barely be able to touch your toes.
Like Ah,
ah.
So you can travel with one of those,
throw that video on and have a great workout.
But for most people with the most important thing is just building up slow.
Don't try to get it all like,
I haven't worked out in five years.
So today I'm fucking running the mountain.
I'm going to do click.
No,
no.
Go light to a little bit of work today,
but be consistent.
That's the key.
Be consistent like little bit of work.
One day.
Re Relax,
rest a little bit more.
Workout the next day.
Relax,
rest,
chart your progress and then what you said,
listen to your body.
Well,
I could finally do a technical,
get up a Turkish,
get up.
No,
a technical get up and Jujitsu.
I can finally do it after a year of practice of it in hotel rooms.
Five a day.
I would do on my right side.
The fact that you know I'm a nut thug.
You do know him.
Retarded half where people know that I'm a little stupid.
I'm Geeky,
I don't like,
I don't like being bad at something and since we got the comedy work ethic,
I know that you could turn anything.
His wife,
it's just something if you just keep showing up.
Yeah.
If you just,
you don't like the major.
Jitu has been,
I sucked Joe,
but I could finally do the whole gym hip escape.
That fucking,
I'm a black belt.
The HIPAA scapes to me today.
That's what I do.
I'm a hip escape expert.
That's what I work on.
You know?
Uh,
if it's games a huge fucking,
when you learn how to do it for six months,
I didn't know what I was doing and then Salami taught me sometimes all just
taught me a different and I put it all together,
how my shoulder and now at least I could pick up my ass and push it all the way
back for me.
Those are little things,
you know,
I wish I was better,
but I know if I keep going to Jujitsu twice a week,
which is what my body can handle.
Eventually I'll get somebody in an arm bar eventually.
Cause I got funny with Combi.
I was no fucking just slip Magoo in the beginning I said whatever.
I just kept showing up.
You just got to keep showing the fuck up.
That's half of life.
That's how for life and who gives a fuck.
I want,
I'm not looking for a black belt.
I'm not even looking to go to beat nobody up.
I'm just looking to go to learn how a Turkish get up.
I could do with 10 pounds of Turkish get up.
I'm up to this point where I put my arm down.
I put my knee up and I just go up to my elbow and I go down and I do tell her
that was bro Bop,
bop,
bop.
I don't even go off,
but I've been doing it for eight months.
Kettlebells 10 pounds,
Turkish get up,
bitch,
but I'm still doing it right.
What would happen if I woulda took 35 pounds?
You know me dog.
I get that.
I wouldn't be here right now.
My shoulder would be at my fucking Hylo,
so,
but at least I know this going in because because of the lesson I got from
comedy that it don't matter.
Don't just keep showing up.
Yeah,
but nobody lasts him.
Dog.
Keep showing him.
Some people,
you tell them stay home.
Some people just don't want man.
For some people it's like me.
When we did comedy,
that was eight who had a chance.
That was another six who were funny,
but they had day jobs because they were married or had children.
Then you had two people do as a hobby that every once in a great while they
drove to a Gig and then you got three people that just had mental health issues.
Yeah.
Okay,
so he showed up every week and they were nice enough,
but she knew there was something wrong there and for them it was the way this is
for me with Jujitsu,
I'm not looking for them.
You,
they're not looking to be on NBC.
All they want to do is one time in their life,
make somebody laugh.
How special is that?
It's huge.
And they go down there and you miss those guys.
I missed those guys from my scenes and see how he'd been here and that way
there's people that you see them and they're a pleasure to talk to because they
don't want an agent.
They don't want to be on movies that just having fun.
They work at universal city in the daytime as the hope.
You know?
There's very few of those [inaudible] appreciate that.
I respect that man.
But I did very,
there's very few of those.
Most of those guys have dreams that just never manifested themselves,
but a lot of them never material.
I met a lot of guys that bro,
they were proud of their job.
They just thought somewhere in their life that they could be a standup and they
just didn't want to die without trying it.
And then they did it and it become addicted.
How many people go to Jujitsu?
It becomes addictive.
You know,
standup definitely becomes a dick and that becomes addictive.
It becomes addicting and it's like addicts where you see those guys that are
scrambled outside,
they can't wait to get on stage and like even guys who are bad,
they'll see a guy who's up there killing like you'd be up to their killing.
Like man,
he's supposed to only be doing 15 minutes,
motherfuckers at 20 minutes.
Like what do you care?
What are you going to do?
You're going to go up after Joey Diaz,
what are you going to do?
You're an open miker and you're upset.
Like they think somehow or another they,
while I'm on the non paid regulus but you're not getting up until two in the
morning.
You know how it works.
This is what you do.
You're on a non paid,
I was a non paid regular.
You get up after everybody else.
That's what you do.
If there's anybody
craziest that people should know this,
you want to,
you were on a TV show and you wouldn't pay regular,
which by law if you're on a TV show,
you're allowed to go in there and bump bitches.
Give him the bell.
You know what I'm saying?
Well,
not only that,
I showed up every night,
every night I was there every night
about this whole thing from you.
It was newsradio on Fridays.
You got that 11 in the morning,
wardrobe,
stupidity,
laughter,
food,
and then at eight o'clock your shoot,
you'd be strolling in there and fucking 1130 bro.
I respect you for that.
Until this day that meant more than me and you didn't need it and it's $15 it's
not like you had 19 yeah,
kids,
you need the 15 fucking dollars.
I'll tell you the truth.
Being passed as a paid regular at the comedy store meant more to me.
Getting on a TV show.
Me Too.
When I was on a TV show when I was on news radio,
one of the things I love about you coming to visit me,
I was like,
finally,
there's another motherfucker doesn't belong here.
Because I was,
I was always wandering around like one day they're going to tell me to get the
fuck off TB,
but until now somehow or another I'm on TV.
So Joey would show up.
I'd be like,
come here man.
Hey,
come here.
Let me show you what this,
this is where they keep the food,
wander around the set.
Joey would show up at the set and Joey would be sitting.
They had an executives,
a VIP suite and the VIP suite.
They had shrimp cocktails and delicious hors d'oeuvres and they had it catered.
A dude who you know had like one of those Mumford and sons fucking facial hair
things with a beautiful tie,
a thin,
skinny tie.
He'd be like serving people shit.
And it would be all these NBC executives and Joey fucking Diaz with a leather
jacket,
which stroll in and and feast.
He'd be sitting there with a fucking paper plate with like 15 shrimps on it all.
But God,
is that your friend?
Can I ask you,
some has ever been a week that you caught yourself after a couple of days and
you've gone,
fuck,
why am in such a bad mood?
You're like,
I got to get on stage.
You will.
Definitely.
I do it all the time.
Guys.
Like I fucking go frantic.
Like for two nights I go,
I'm gonna stay in,
right.
I'm going to be George Carlin.
It needs to go up by fucking Thursday.
I'm salivating.
By Thursday morning I wake up with that fucker.
And also I'm on the flappers website.
I wanted the ice house website.
I'm looking for a spot,
you know,
I don't call him no way.
I'm just looking,
you know?
Well,
it's a fucking,
it's definitely an addiction,
but definitely that's a positive addiction.
Yes,
definitely in the more addicted you,
like right now I'm super addicted.
Sure.
You got big things going on,
but I was thinking August I,
yeah,
I got my special that I'm going to fit record in August with the tickets are
still,
haven't been on sale for it yet,
but it's going to be at the comedy works in Denver and a,
I'm doing it in the little club to downtown club.
That's ferocious.
It's like a den of thieves,
so geared up for this.
I can't fucking wait back to day one,
which I understand like you're writing again.
You're looking at little words now and that gets you fired up all over again and
that really does well.
I'm just right now,
I've never been more excited about up then.
Right now I'm so,
I'm so into it,
but all the other things that I do,
I love working for the UFC.
I love it.
I love doing podcasts,
but stand up right now is my mother fucker.
I just,
I'm just enjoying it so much.
I'm enjoying watching it.
I'm enjoying doing it and my joint writing it.
I'm excited about it.
It's fun.
It's a fun time,
you know,
and the Ice House man,
the Ice House has helped me a lot.
Having that place where we,
we perform there on a regular basis.
How has a cool staff and everybody's not in Bob,
the owner,
just being such a good guy.
It's gets such a good vibe in these shows that we've been and we've got to show
their tonight these shows that we do there.
They're so fucking fun.
Tonight's Ian Edwards,
Brian Cowen,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
Sam Tripoli,
me,
we're going to murder that thing that places a special,
like a magnet for fun.
There's a lot of fun times.
Fuck yeah,
it's,
at times it's everything that the comedy store used to be,
but positive.
There's no negativity there.
There's no darkness that like hovers over the place.
It's not the same.
But we're at different times in our life.
And what was good about the comedy store when I was 25 is not good about the
comedy store now,
you know,
I don't,
I don't want that nonsense in my life anymore.
But what's good about the ice house is like all the good things,
like an old comedy club with like a lot of history,
but none of the pretentiousness.
None of that bullshit.
Not Stuck on sunset.
So Dick wads come over from the sky bar,
all that,
you know,
all the,
the,
the element that you get in Hollywood,
that extra Dick Wad fucking actor element.
You don't get that in Pasadena.
Pasadena is just all positive.
I would tell you something,
man.
I uh,
I'm doing the ice house next weekend with Dabo forever,
you know,
and I just called them,
this is the truth guys.
I was talking to her dad on the phone and I had the computer open and something
like,
well,
let me see if he's got like a recent set to see what he's doing.
You know,
dot Marrero always writing and dog.
I put the set on from Rodney and I gotta be honest here.
I had tears going down my eyes.
I'm so proud of myself.
It was so like,
I remember watching that fucking special and just getting anxiety from going.
Jesus,
I'll never be that fucking good.
Like my God,
not as a comic,
but he was a human being.
Like,
here I am in a halfway house watching this fucking tape of ham and Bill Hicks
and dice and God knows who else is on that.
Lenny Clark,
you know I love Lindy Clark from the beginning,
Bro.
Austin.
I'm like,
I'll never be as good to be here I am next weekend.
I'm at the fucking ice house with them.
Herrera Co headline,
are you fucking kidding me?
I mean,
I you fucking serious.
That means more than any movie,
because I remember that dream a couple of weeks ago.
I'm an Austin,
Texas at the bar having a salad and who comes up and gives me a hug?
Joe Torry.
Listen,
man.
Joe Torry used to have a routine of def jam where he used to talk about,
yeah,
I got a brother that's one of them saved.
Well,
motherfuckers,
not me.
I love mother.
Fuck,
I just bought a gun.
I can't wait to use it.
In fact,
I go to the ATM every night with a Tuxedo on his shit.
You know how many times I fucking watched that stupidity,
that fucking,
uh,
all stars and dom are errors.
I sat there for hours going,
what a shame that on.
I'll never be in that.
Not In this lifetime.
I have to come back as a decent human being and
get my shit be reborn as a decent human being.
Fucking,
you're a very decent human being.
Not at that time when I'd be watching that,
should I go,
okay,
so maybe if I do this for 20 years,
it might be a little funny,
but I'll never be as Joe Torry and every time I see to try to tell him the same
thing,
I'm going to get more fucking Tuxedo and I'm going go dial ATM at midnight and
Shit.
You know?
It's just very weird the times what's going on right now.
Yeah.
You see people,
it's awesome.
It's awesome.
It's awesome to see the culmination of years and years and work for me.
It's beautiful because I got to see you really early on.
I mean,
I got to see you.
You don't want me doing comedy like a couple of years.
When I first met six is it was a mess.
It was you wrote six years in when I met you.
Yeah.
That's probably,
I started in 91 92 but when you came to the comedy store,
that's when he got real serious.
Right.
Mitzi shore touches you.
You got told you.
You had started in,
you did Denver and South Seattle.
Those are the two spots.
Seattle was where I,
the lights got turned it on and Denver,
I was just going up.
It's like Jujitsu.
I just go there fucking around and if he lets me grab his call,
I grabbed his collar.
If he takes me down,
so be it.
If I get them down,
wow.
Oh my God,
well now what do I do?
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
That's what comedy was for me in Denver,
but then I started doing time.
I started doing wait 24 minutes and then this opportunity came up in Seattle,
so I went to Seattle and Seattle was where there was an open mic.
It was 18 comics on an open mic.
On Mondays and Tuesdays.
There was another open mic after that open like I another open Mike.
After that opened my and Tuesday there was another open mind and these are all
piece in places in Denver.
I had the calmer,
you know head to had a guy in the head with a microphone and Denver one time
cause he was flicking bottle caps at the comics.
They test drove.
If I still see Dave test drove today,
he'll go,
what's happening killer because I fucking hit this guy in the head with a
microphone.
Batteries what?
Everywhere you don't meet God.
I told them if you flick one fucking thing up here,
I'm a break this microphone over your fucking head.
What did he do with his buddy?
Click burn.
They gave me 25 bucks gift certificate and I had to get the fuck out of it and I
took my steak to go.
I'm going to forget that.
And Denver you had,
you had no comedy on Mondays I had the Australian Barton Boulder,
which does not exist there anymore.
On Tuesdays I had Wendy ten three minutes.
You got twice a month,
three minutes at the comedy works in those days.
Wednesdays you at club 52,
Thursdays you had El Torito and uh,
by John Elway up there by John Elway's and Englewood,
Colorado where all Cherry hill all the way up.
Dad El Torito.
As soon as you got off the ice 70,
and on Friday and Saturday,
you an open Mike.
You had dick,
you know how many fucking places I hadn't Seattle on a Friday night.
You know how many places you had on a Wednesday night?
You got to coma,
you had Seattle,
you had Everett,
you had Bellingham on Sundays.
More comics.
When I think Seattle,
Seattle,
you know,
just the core I had was me,
Brody,
Josh Wolfe,
I,
you should tailor went through there,
you know,
I know.
Well they wouldn't San Francisco.
So I knew a lot of those people at the festivals and at the,
the comedy competition and then the hand,
you know,
Steve McGrew,
Todd Jordan had some hitters too,
but the open mic scene wasn't that strong.
It was very in Denver.
Seattle did that.
But there was one guy,
his name was Andy Peyton.
He was a fucking dead tremendous guy.
He's a mayor of a town.
He ran for politics.
He was a genius.
He went to all these bars and he got a night in each bar.
They paid them a little bit.
Every night you
got a little bit 20 bucks,
10 bucks,
30 bucks,
but at least you got to go on stage.
Andy paid and also sold advertising and pulled out a newspaper,
I think.
Aye.
I give a lot of credit to my career,
to Andy,
to you and to Mitzi shore,
but Andy painted believes in me the way Dick Dardy believed in you because he
didn't give a fuck that I was dirty.
But that mother fucker roommate Brian Sundays,
he goes,
I'll give you 50 bucks.
You've got to follow a line dancing class and Colorado Jack,
Achy,
breaky heart bitch,
and I'd be the first comic up at the Achy breaky heart.
You want to talk about hate?
You want to talk about no laughter.
He give me 50 bucks on Sunday and in those days,
on Sundays at seven,
I used to drop my daughter off and as soon as I slammed the door,
I just go into tears and I'd get on the seventh day and I'd smoke a joint and by
the time I get to the Gig I'd be brand fucking new and I'd go on that stage just
to die.
It was like a day are dying.
It was like five hours of my daughter and I took their abuse and then I had,
I would go to this bar and fucking Arvada.
You've never even been taught about it.
Oh,
you see the signs where Duane Ludwig is from Arvada
and I'd have to do this fucking country barn on Sunday night.
Andy page them was a genius Bro.
He had two of those weeks.
So he would call you and go,
you got the whole week and I'm talking to Monday through Sunday,
40 30 they weren't two hour drive,
so it would just dumped bars and way before the stadium went up.
This is what,
that shit was a shit hole down there really.
And the comedy works.
Told him you're not allowed in here because you got all you can get girl
competition.
So he said,
really I'm a while,
I'm going to teach you motherfuckers a lesson.
He spanked him for about a year and a half though.
But then he moved,
he went to like one of those small towns and he uh,
became the mayor.
It became a mayor.
Man.
I know he's on Facebook and I think I went back and forth with them at one time.
I thanked them and that's what he says.
He's still does come here once a month in this town.
He went to like a town.
Imagine the mayor's doing stand up in your town and that's what maybe a mayor
for a long time.
There's a term limits.
I'm being a man.
Nah,
cause the man from North Bergen may have saccos been there fucking at least
fucking 10 years.
12 years.
Okay.
You can't,
there's no term limits on Supreme Court justices.
Right.
And not like something that people don't like it.
It's different in places in Ohio and Cincinnati.
The term limit is two successive.
A four year terms is different in different places apparently.
Huh?
That's gotta be a thankless fucking job being the mayor of a town,
trying to keep everybody in order.
There's crime in this town,
mayor.
We want me to do the fuck are we going to do?
I'm going to stop the crime and stop people from stealing shit.
Do it the bad that it might.
Tyler.
Josie put cameras up around the city.
That's communism.
Why fucking come from Doug [inaudible] and the city on the street?
We know Camden.
You know Campbell in that police officer's anymore.
Camden is so broke.
There's just ramping crime police officers.
So you know what they did?
They just put cameras up everywhere,
everywhere.
Some Robo cop shit.
They're like living in the future.
I got a secret for you motherfuckers.
I knew Camden was the real deal in 1978 I couldn't believe what I had.
So,
and what'd you say?
I saw anarchy.
I've been robbed one time on the street and a drug deal.
One time in my life.
Did I get drunk,
robbed on the street and the drug dealer was in Camden,
New Jersey.
They don't fuck around and then can then bro Penn saucon can then that's a
complete different world.
I got robbed for a pound of coke.
I pound the weed.
I had to go answer the people that gave me money,
investors.
I had to go pay these people back and sell weed and I had to do what I had to
do.
I fucked up,
but they robbed me,
man.
They sent me to fuck up.
Camden is the poorest city in the country and it has the highest rate of murder
in the country.
No Shit.
They got no cop on the street.
It's an animal.
Canon Mother fucking New Jersey,
New Jersey.
We played them one year in basketball and Dennis still,
I'll never forget,
there's a coach in our high school that was in a wheelchair.
He got paralyzed.
Dennis still went up to him to spit in his fucking face dog in high school.
When you spit in the handicap dude's face,
Jesus,
you ain't fucking around.
You want to hear a crazy crime statistic.
Camden,
New Jersey and has the crime rate of 78% per 1000 residents.
So for every 1000 residents,
78% of them are going to experience crime.
78%.
That's like,
how much crime do you experience in Burbank?
0% did you get 78 he got robbed by Dracula.
This fucking guy,
he was probably really loud and
bought a pistol.
Blackwoods or the plaque was,
I know Camden.
I had never seen anything like that.
Then I had a buddy,
a basketball player buddy.
I was putting pen soccer and I went down to the visit,
his family once and I left there with my fucking jaw dropped and I knew not to
go back down there.
I read all these Kansas statistics now and I'm like,
no shit.
That place was the edge of health dirty fucking years ago.
I can't imagine what it is now.
Yeah.
Matt Taibbi wrote an article about it.
I'm tweeting it right now.
He wrote an article about,
uh,
Camden saying it's called Apocalypse New Jersey.
Uh,
dispatch from America's most desperate town.
No jobs,
no hope and surveillance cameras everywhere.
The strange,
sad story of Camden.
That's the population.
That's a good question.
What if it's like 14 people?
You know there's a lot of fucking people that surrounds Camden brother.
Take a look for you,
uncle Joe.
Shit around New Jersey,
near Atlantic city.
Right,
right,
right.
It's,
I thought it was near Philadelphia too,
probably.
Yeah,
it's across the Delaware River from Philly.
There's a 77,000 people.
If you don't want to get fucked up,
don't go to camp and Jack,
don't buy weed.
Don't do nothing.
I got tricked.
They used to be this gas station,
not Bergen went on from called Putnam,
and when I became,
after my mom died,
I had an inside guy and I robbed them once a month,
like a fake robbery.
You know what I'm saying?
We'd go hit up in the head,
he'd go down and we'd take a thousand and all he wanted was an eight ball.
He was a little half on the Patato sake robbery,
all tremendous.
I worked at Putnam fuel.
Everybody from that high school work that Putin and fuel and you robbed them to
death until they find you.
Ernie was always a shift manager and he had kids.
He was going to fucked up melting.
I love cocaine,
man.
Me and my wife love with his wife was like 400 pounds.
She didn't work.
You know,
he had to bring the home fucking almond joys,
that type of shit.
He worked at a gas station.
They live in a terrible apartment,
but they were cocaine heads and I was 16 and I had worked and he's telling me I
need eight ball and I go,
honey,
how can we do just,
how can we make this happen?
And one day he's like,
you can fake rob me.
Alright rob.
He's like one dog.
You know how many times I fake rob dirty?
I'm about six times.
In fact,
there's a kid in Florida has a story that I showed up at his house one night
with a,
with a diagram,
cause you had a Robin in the same way you had to go around the building.
It was cameras in the front in those days you got to go around the back,
ring the bell.
When he come out,
he had to attack.
I couldn't be the same guy all the time.
That rob them,
but you were going to be fine.
You weren't going to get arrested.
Just take the walk and me,
trust me,
and he always took.
Now whenever he goes to the comedy show goes,
he goes,
I'm in the cocoa coming home.
When they were the diagram,
I were going to rob a gas station,
like a football player because it was brilliant.
I Rob Ernie once a fucking every six weeks.
The cotton where you had to hit him,
you got to kick him in the stomach and shit and like smack him so he would bleed
and the cops,
he would say,
Ernie,
nobody gets robbed like this one.
What do you want me to tell you?
They know I'm a fucking idiot,
bro.
We would rob them once every six weeks and finally it ended.
I didn't bring him the eight ball
when that I just did as a boy.
He got pissed off at me and that was it.
Being around shady people like that,
I'd grown up.
Brunch 80 people gives you such a,
a different flavor to life just is.
There's an extra element when you look at the time,
it's probably a little dangerous when you look back on it and laugh.
There's so many w work at this gas station.
I worked at a gas station for a little while and it was this old guy who used to
come in the gas station.
This old dude who had like one of those classic bald guys.
He was balled up top of the hair on the side,
looked like,
you know,
you see a guy like that.
You think he's like a normal guy?
Probably an off,
no.
This guy used to drive the souped up Buick and he was a total pervert and all he
could do was talk about pussy.
This old man talking about pussy,
like gray hair on the sides of his head,
just talking about finger and chicks and fucking shit like he was a madman.
But being around that guy made me realize that like I see a dude like an old
dude who's bald with the fucking hair on the side.
And I say,
well this is probably a nice gentlemen.
Like,
no,
it's the old pervert driving a hot rod Buick finger and chicks.
She realize you're around people like that.
You know that there's something else.
Like there's possibilities.
There's,
there's a lot of different kinds of people in life and sometimes just because
someone looks like someone that you've sort of already met before,
like,
Oh yeah,
I know that type.
No you don't.
You have no idea.
Look at Ted Bundy.
That was how Ted Bundy got all those girls.
He looked like a normal handsome guy.
He didn't look like some Ed gain fucking psychopath with
creepy little beady eyes.
Weird strange man was strained,
yelled to eat when to catch you up and tying you into the lamp.
No,
he looked like a guy that you'd want to date a Mark Harmon play them.
Yeah.
That was a goal when he escaped from the jail.
It fucking,
that has been through a window for a while.
I thought I was crazy though.
Cause I lived everywhere with Ted Bundy lived for a while.
I thought I was crazy.
I lived in Snowmass village.
He killed the check.
He kidnapped her from the Willow Brook Hotel,
whatever,
in Snowmass village.
And then we looked to Seattle.
That's where he did most of his damage.
That was Seattle.
He did.
Didn't he do some in Florida?
Florida was at the end of the dormitory.
Oh,
that was the end.
I think looking up something for a long time.
I'm like,
maybe I'm fucking crazy dog.
I keep living everywhere and I mean,
I'm not mean.
I mean,
and and snowmen.
yeah,
he escaped from the,
asked me to fucking jail.
Ted Bondi.
That was a,
that was a scary one.
That guy used to,
he used to pick up girls and take them for rides in his car and they realized
there was no door knob on their side.
They would go to reach for like the door to open it.
There's no door knob he would remove.
He had the door knobs were removed and the side of his car,
2002 film Ted Bundy be looking at him.
He's a handsome guy.
Normal looking dude.
Is he still alive?
They launched that kill him.
Yeah,
he was in Aspen.
Remember they launched them.
And,
uh,
they celebrated his death and all the towns we killed people.
They had happy hours that drinks the Bundy and shit.
Yeah.
January 24th,
1989,
they killed him.
He was age 42 at the Florida state.
Yeah.
Does he represent himself?
He was an attorney by letting them know by,
I think he was,
he,
he was,
he didn't take the test to something.
He did a lot of crazy shit,
man.
Fuck yeah.
He killed a lot of girls,
man.
He revisited
secondary crime scenes for hours at a time.
Grooming and performing sexual acts with the decomposing corpse is until future
vacation and destruction by wild animals made further interaction.
Impossible.
He decapitated at least 12 of his victims and kept some of the severed heads in
his apartment for a period of time as momentos on a few occasions,
he simply broke into dwellings at night and bludgeons his victims as they slept.
Man,
he was their first kidnapped.
They first got him in 1975 for aggravated kidnapping and attempted criminal
assault.
And then he became a suspect and it progressively longer list of unsolved
homicides and multiple states.
Fuck,
call it Colorado and Florida.
Ah,
God.
Damn.
Florida finally launched him,
correct?
Yup.
The dormitory.
That's where he got the girls at the University of Florida,
right?
Gainesville,
wasn't it in Gainesville or something like that?
Yeah,
there's some,
there's a lot of those fucking guys out there,
man.
It's like what?
What turns a guy like Ted Bundy and to someone who would do that shit.
Damn.
Have you seen his morgue picks?
Morgan pig?
Yeah.
When they ain't got executed,
I guess.
Yeah.
Picks of it.
It's like there's a color one.
There's a black and white one.
Uh,
a prom with more pixus.
Who the fuck knows if that's real?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes.
Yeah.
It didn't look good.
Shaved his head too.
Yeah.
Top of his head.
It looks like it blew up or something.
And that's what they do when they're cooking you.
Yeah.
Scary shit man.
It's just scary shit that someone could be like that.
Yeah.
Motherfucker killed catch when he was six.
Killed dogs is shit tortured Michael Victim.
It's shit.
The fucking,
yeah.
There's though he's bludgeoning women in their fucking sleep and rape and
corporates is what the fuck happens to people,
Bro.
Yeah.
That is the question.
The fuck happens to people.
What is it about people that a switch can go off and then boom,
all of a sudden you're Dylan Klebold and Colorado shooting up your school.
What is it,
what,
what combination of chemicals and behavior in life,
what combinations of curve balls and shitty genetics and all sorts of different
things cause someone to be that way?
His,
uh,
his beetle was on display in a museum recently.
They found,
uh,
in it they found a bunch of items that were in it.
And one was a crow bar,
Eh,
uh,
garage garbage bags and ice pick,
a flashlight,
torn strips of sheeting,
a nit ski mask,
handcuffs,
and a strange mask made from panty hose.
What the fuck?
And in Florida living in Florida wasn't bad enough.
You got to deal with that guy riding around.
Imagine if ted money was alive today.
How big 90% of Nancy Grace's show
Ted Bundy and full Laura.
Uh,
Florida's a wild fucking places you stand up to.
It was one of the wildest spots I was thinking that the other day like that,
that Hollywood Improv,
the Improv in Fort Lauderdale,
Hollywood,
Florida,
Dad fucking Improv is one of the wildest clubs in the goddamn country as Brian
counts favorite place to perform.
He's like,
they're off the chain there.
Their animals.
It was just a mosaic where you,
what'd you do?
What'd you do it with?
But did you bring anybody with you or you don't know?
They will like,
no,
you have to pay like $800 for a hotel for the Brigham features the casino
because they put you in the casino.
They don't give you a second hotel room.
You get to make them give you a second.
It was like they have a hotel room.
I,
you know,
I thought it was in a casino is going to be boring.
It wasn't that bad.
It was pretty good.
As a matter of fact,
I had a good time.
Yeah,
it's a fun,
great time.
I really didn't have a good time.
If you live in around there,
that hard rock.
So decent passive.
No.
Yeah,
no,
it was great.
It sounds like those places where they do,
they used to do king of the cage in the of the band days.
Did you ever go to the one of those with me?
No.
Eddie Bravo and I went to a bunch of them and he used to work for the king,
the cage.
He was the posts,
the commentator.
So we would travel sometimes to these,
these gigs were in the middle of fucking,
I mean know where these weird native American casinos where the only places
where he could do it because they had sovereignty over their own land.
So even though MMA was banned in California at the time,
they could still put on fights these casinos and that's when people started to
wake up because he's like,
what?
Why are we making this illegal?
You don't much fucking money these people are making,
because you would go to the middle of nowhere.
I mean hours and hours drive and there would be thousands of people there for an
event.
All people.
We knew people we knew from Jujitsu guys.
We trained with guys.
We knew that we're like tap the tap out guys and the early days and we would go
there and they'd have these outdoor arenas like these outdoors,
like seated state.
Most of the time,
no cover over it.
If it rained,
the fights kept going.
They made a whole DVD called wet and wild where they let it rain.
It was fucking pouring out and the middle of these crazy torrential downpours
dudes were fighting.
It's not a bad idea.
It's the dumbest idea of all time,
but yet no traction at all.
You would throw upon,
she would fucking go fly in because they had one of those old school vinyl
floors.
If it was a canvas floor,
it would still be slippery,
but it would be less slippery.
But this shit wasn't canvas.
This shit was like like vinyl,
so it was like a swimming pool.
It's like slip and slide.
It really was like trying to have a kickboxing match on slip and slide.
Dudes fallen s little knees get blown out,
fall on top of each other like it was like one of the sloppiest Emma May cards
ever,
but kind of fun because it's a piece of history.
I don't think they should ever do it again,
but it's good that it exists.
I think this is probably a,
probably a pull down from youtube.
We put a video on our [inaudible].
That's funny.
If you ever go to boulder again,
they'll make sure you go to the rope institute.
NEROPA institute.
What does,
that's a cool mother.
I,
what is this?
That place?
It's a Buddhist college.
Really?
I went down on Monday.
I used to go to when I was fucked up in the head,
right.
I thought I didn't know what I want to do with my life.
I was confused after prison.
I didn't know when I would go there on Mondays I'm walking,
meditate.
I learned how to meditate there.
I went to a seminar,
she didn't Halloween Ginsburg there and you know it's all vegetarians.
Fuck though.
Like I went to a massage therapist and that was tremendous.
The only time I ever allowed myself,
she stunk so bad.
But the massages were so good,
but I could smell her fucking arm pits in the is something that I was fucking
hard,
but they were the nicest fucking people in the world.
And they always have a course that you'll look at it and go,
Huh,
like class,
they're teaching.
Like,
you know what man,
I was young,
I was maybe 30 I didn't know right before Cami,
I was frustrated.
I was married,
I didn't know.
And I go there.
I remember taking like a humanitarian course,
you know?
But it was so I think that it would be more interesting to me because now I've
gained more knowledge.
I know what the fuck I am.
So if you ever go there again,
I never mentioned it to you.
My friend owns the cafeteria and it's a vegetarian cafeteria,
but every once in a while he's a Spanish dude.
He whips up some bad ass shit Levy.
Yeah,
man.
And He,
it was weird how he took over it.
And I always forget to tell you about the,
I don't know if you ever go back to boulder,
but if you do check it out.
I even go on the web page.
Just look,
they always have some fucking genius gone through there.
Drop him bad ass knowledge.
Listen,
if you want to see the stones,
you go to the garden.
If you want to see a good fight,
you got to God.
If you want to see a smart,
keen,
bad ass motherfucker,
drop knowledge,
go to Naropa.
Really go to boulder.
Boulder's got some fucking,
you know we met,
look at Bro,
they have elite martial artists to have elite MMA guys and Bulger.
They got a float tank business to have a float tank.
They have everything in bold.
I mean that's an astronaut school.
So there's people who have,
it's amazing the quality of people.
I met boulder that I judged that I was like blown away by now.
It's a great town just because you,
because you know when you meet a physicist and he meets a guy like me,
he looks down on me in boulder.
Those motherfuckers talk to you.
And then they tell you about,
I've,
I've stabbed a motherfucker one time.
You know what?
You went to Yale,
you got to fucking masters from Harvard.
Yeah.
You know,
one time some guy,
you know,
because that fucking so extreme.
Just because they're geniuses and that level doesn't mean that nerds,
Bro,
if,
especially if they moved,
the bulk of it might be hunters.
Like I know a guy that was a fucking brilliant dude,
but he was like a race.
You know,
he's a guy,
he's a racist.
He's like a KKK racist,
I believe,
because he was dad accentuate Joe.
You posted something the other day,
six geniuses who are perverts.
What does it,
Bro,
when you become that deep,
I would go to the rope and listen.
The GINSBURG is one of the guys.
I remember I probably went to four seminars there that to listen to people speak
and everybody had samples on it.
It was Vegan.
But I grasp a lot of fucking different things.
Man,
that helped me,
you know,
I remember going there one time and going,
maybe the Catholic religion is bullshit the way this motherfucker was dropping
it right.
They weren't asking you to donate.
They weren't asking you to join.
They didn't want you to be Richard Gere.
I knew the Dalai Lama was going there.
Probably alum is always swinging in boulder or he used to some,
somebody from that tribe goes to that Neropa no,
sure.
Every interesting bro.
Oh,
and I always forgot to ask you,
in your travels and anybody ever approach you and Sam or somebody from the
Europa?
No,
it's so,
it's a Buddhist university.
It's like,
look at how this college buddy spell it.
Uh,
and a ROP.
A very fucking cool and,
oh,
I like the mind of a fucking thief and Roper University.
And they would get through to them.
Like,
I was like,
wow,
these fucking people are cool as shit because when you make judgment,
you're like,
oh,
this just,
cause this guy went to og or whatever and he's not going to be interested in
smoking a joint.
Oh,
this mother fucker's got a pound their suitcase on.
I'm the microscope.
You know,
like he grew with it.
Something you're like,
wow.
Yeah.
Um,
I went to a,
an Osram when I was in boulder.
They were then an Osram and the mountains,
like a beauty shots.
Hey,
we just meditate up there in the mountains and kill bugs,
you know,
Buddhist and not supposed to kill bugs.
It's lady had a bug spray.
I go,
what are you doing?
And she goes like,
we have an ant problem.
I go,
wait a minute.
You know,
you're a Buddhist.
You're not supposed to be spraying fucking bugs.
Like that's like convenient.
It's very convenient of you that you spraying aunt medication or ant poison out
and not supposed to do that.
She said she has.
Yeah.
Well it's very unfortunate,
but we really have a uh,
you know,
cleanliness issues and this,
I go,
listen,
you're not supposed to kill fucking ants.
Like that's half the like how about vegans that have cats?
Guess what?
Fuck face.
You're not a Vegan.
Okay.
If you have a cat and you're a Vegan and you're feeding your cat cat food,
you're feeding your cat,
murdered animals,
you are buying murdered animals.
You,
yourself,
you,
yourself are responsible for the death of animals.
Period.
Fact Jamie Kilstein,
all you fucking people that are vegans and post photos of your cats,
those cats are murderers.
That's the only thing cats do.
If you have a cat and you tried to keep figure cat Vieten,
Vegan cat food,
they fucking go blind.
They start shitting themselves,
start walking into walls.
They don't get enough protein.
You can't feed them Vegan cat food.
They can't.
They can't exist like you go to forums like Vegan cat forms.
It's hilarious because post after post you see people saying,
well,
I've finally given in and I had to start feeding my cat regular cat food.
Of course your dad,
he's a little murderer.
You're catch a murderer is.
You're a person who believes that animals shouldn't die,
but you're contributing to those animals dying so that you feed your animal that
kills animals.
Do you understand how crazy this all is?
That highlights the whole hypocrisy of the idea of not taking life.
You take life.
Everybody takes life like takes like takes life.
Life takes life whether you like it or not.
Unfortunately,
it doesn't mean that you can't be a really good person and have a cat and only
contribute to a certain amount of cat murder.
Because look at these cats eat year,
next dirty monsters,
bread down,
but still dirty monsters at heart.
You,
you know the idea behind it is hilarious.
And I don't mean to single out the reason why I did it.
It's because somebody,
a vegans that I've run into who are these self righteous fuckers,
we'll take pictures with their cats like look at you.
That's not
being a Vegan.
You're bi,
you're spending money to get animals killed.
That's a fact.
Unless you're out there like unless you just let your cat forge for itself,
then you just live with a murderer.
You know you're a Vegan who lives with a murderer.
But if you're a Vegan,
he ground,
they're buying cat food.
Guess what dude?
You Ain't a Vegan.
This is going to be a bit,
I hope so because I'm dying to the left with your fucking face.
Right?
Cause I actually listened to vegans.
It's getting deep with you lately.
We'll go on a wall with this a fuck cause it's going to war.
It's kind of on a wall like Tony Month that we can sell is my lower.
We're going to war.
He's like,
what?
We were going to war against self righteousness.
That's what it is.
It's it's people listen,
they miss the big picture.
Look up man,
when you worked at Fairfax,
but I'm sure there was some really cool people and then there was some real
fucking Douche bags when we went to bold,
let me tell you something man.
There was some lovely people in Boulder admin.
Brilliant,
brilliant,
and then they,
again,
this,
the people who are,
there's people out there,
60% of these people that pick a fucking hobby or whatever the fuck they call it
to hobby,
Bro.
It's a social activity anymore.
Religions have become a social activity.
You understand me?
Nobody becomes,
you know,
somebody does something.
It's because they really believe in it.
They really want to do it.
Not Anymore.
Dog and I don't even want dog people join something just to be a part of
something.
It's a social whatever.
That's a lot of it.
It's,
it's,
it's
social brownie points to take it every day to take the high ground.
I'm bored,
I'm lonely.
What am I going to do?
I got three windows.
I might be gay.
I might save cats.
You know,
I was in Hollywood one day and I meet him and there was a guy behind me and he
was gay and I'm like,
this guy can not be this gauge,
Jamie,
this guy can,
I couldn't even not pay that guy because nobody's that game.
But there are people that gay,
this guy was that gay like two gay,
like,
Oh my God.
The whole thing,
the Cologne,
the scarf around the neck,
you know,
those guys that overdo it.
The Guy I could not develop,
but the guy,
I kidnapped my partner,
but it was going to be getting that mean I should stab myself every day for
having him as my partner.
He had everything I needed to be a guy.
He had a pit bull.
He had a black car with tinted windows and a loud stereo.
He had a motorcycle.
He had a tattoo.
He hung out at strip clubs.
He was that guy.
He was the common God.
You know,
who's your connection?
I can't tell you that right now.
Shut the fuck up.
You know he was that guy.
You know,
it's the same thing in life and I see it every day.
People that hobbyists,
hobbyists,
this is a hobbyist stuff until the next mind fuck comes up,
you know they dive into something that's a yoga club.
They go that it's socially,
man.
It's socially,
God forbid,
you know,
walking in the street anymore.
Remember when we were kids?
When you ever go to a prom,
what do you call those parties in college?
Yeah,
whatever.
You got a
keg party.
How they salute your people.
It's an American thing
with the fucking Budweiser,
with the label.
So go cause got the bed.
You can't see a label.
They shake your hand.
It's like a thing.
Go and walk the streets in the morning so they're holding.
I belabored,
let you know they're in a certain group I'm in.
I'm drinking a pap spoon out there.
I'm very ironic.
Okay,
but now it's turned into Starbucks.
God forbid a human being doesn't have a Starbucks cup in their hand by eight
o'clock.
This society,
God forbid if you work in an office and six people every day walking with a
Mocha,
soy,
almond,
you know,
gluten free,
sperm free,
fucking double latte.
God forbid the guy who walks in with a seven 11 cup of coffee.
You know what I'm saying?
He's a loser.
It's pretty poor.
We all have to fucking hat that Starbucks cup.
You know it.
Starbucks that fucking great.
Really well.
You know what really is these days when you,
I mean nothing wrong with the coffee,
but with a lot of people are buying.
It's like a super sweet shake.
You're buying a super sweet shake that has caffeine in it,
whipped cream in it and fucking all those,
those venti things that people buy,
those blended things.
Ice Blended,
Vanilla,
soy.
You're,
you're,
it's a shake with drugs in an office dog.
I'm from New Jersey.
Give me that motherfucker black cause white come from black is beautiful.
I The blue shirts gimme don't touch that when you're going to Jersey in the
mornings you drove a limo.
You know what it's like when you go and can you imagine going to a diner in
Boston to go,
you know what?
Let me get some soy milk.
They would throw that fucking black coffee at you for 2000 years.
America drank a fucking from a cup that looked like a bowling ball,
like a helmet that they put in the,
yeah.
Yup.
You got it.
What?
What'd you say to regular?
What was your regular coffee?
We're growing up,
cream and sugar.
A little bit of cream,
but if it increased sugar,
white,
whatever the fuck.
That's it.
You go to Dunkin donuts,
you go ask for a regular coffee.
They give it to you with cream and sugar.
Come on today's stuff.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
Ask Her.
It was like this places we can go to this day.
I have a regular coffee.
The point of cream for your pour,
a couple dashes of sugar for 36,000 years.
Americans ate a buttered roll every motherfucking these coasts hate a buttered
roll.
That's it.
Fuck the egg.
Fuck the gluten.
Fuck the protein angels were butter bagels or button.
I was like,
every fucking corner I wasn't a city would have,
but it was wrapped up roles with,
with butter already buttered or wrapped up.
Bagels are any buttered fucking amazing.
I just needed some calories now.
But now it's like if you don't have a Starbucks fucking coffee.
So that lady you met in bold because,
let me tell you one thing about bold guy.
Believe bold.
The had a lot,
a lot bolder specializes in one thing.
They specialize if you're serious about your health and your life,
uh,
the value of your life.
People who value their lives.
Like somebody lives in a big city and one day he has a heart attack at 33
and he's a stockbroker and yeah,
he's got $30 million in the bank,
but he's fucking 33.
Those guys,
when they degas,
it's over and they moved to bowl and they open up a bookstore
and you don't know,
you walked by there and then go,
how does this fucking Moke make a living?
It's people who want to enhance their lives and people realize that you don't
have to be around as many goddamn people.
I did Kevin and being yesterday,
so I was up at five 50 I was in my car by 6:00 AM driving on the highway,
act
packed fucking 30 miles an hour going down the one on one.
It's six o'clock in the morning.
It was,
it's madness.
God forbid you get there at seven 30 or eight it's death.
It's hot death for a dozen miles and there's too many motherfuckers.
Man,
it's not good for you.
It's not good for you if you have to live here.
I totally understand,
but you and I don't.
We don't have to live here.
We're on the road all the time.
I'm going to start skyping shit in.
I'm going to put Jamie and a God damn fish tank.
I'm going to start skyping from the middle of nowhere.
I'm going to figure out how to do that or he should.
Fear does that.
When he does that punchdrunk podcast,
he's on the,
he's in New York and they're over here that you Skypes.
These guys is a little corner,
a little fucking square.
It's an amazing how if I get on the plane when I travel,
I get to,
I get to 6:00 AM because let me tell you something,
bro.
You going look at me and say,
no way.
There's a huge difference on the four oh five from 10 to six and 10 and a half
to six.
It's miraculous.
Oh yeah.
It's something you'd never say it and I'll do it with you.
I'm going to have five days a week and go,
you're ready?
That's 10 to six.
You see it moving.
Watch 10 after six blank claim.
We'll get an Hov lane.
Look at that motherfucker stuck.
Yup.
Stopped Hov.
Motherfuck doesn't a claw stuck?
No,
man.
I get it.
That fucking car for 45 you only takes me 20 minutes to get the fuck the four oh
five at four in the morning.
Five in the morning.
Oh yeah.
When he finds nothing,
it's beautiful.
You'll city four in the morning.
It's beautiful.
Unbelievable.
I get to the fucking airport.
I park at the three right by the elevator and I'm going to doubt,
you know what I do sometimes if I've got a wild hair up my ass,
I'll take my car up into the mountains.
Like,
do you ever go up Angeles Crest Highway?
I don't know.
Angeles crest highway off the to 10.
If you go off to two 10.
And do you like driving from uh,
like uh,
this studio towards Pasadena?
If you went up,
uh,
through,
um,
the one 18 to the to 10,
there's an area called the Angeles crest highway and he'd take it up into the
mountains,
just a two lane road.
And if you go up there and like five o'clock in the morning,
six o'clock in the morning,
it's fucking dead empty.
And right when the sun starts to come up and just drive,
just drive up there,
just drive up there and see the mountains and the hills and there's not a
fucking sold insight when you could do that.
When you can get on the highway and you see like one car a mile up and one car
like a mile back and that's it.
Just you three motherfuckers from one guy going this way.
One goes,
it's like relaxing.
It gives you a feeling of peace because you're so constantly concentrating on
all these motherfuckers,
this guy next to use in a truck and this guy next to you is kind of weaving in
that Elaine's and this motherfucker in front of you is going too slow and it's
like so much shit to think about when you could just get on a highway and
there's no nobody.
It's a peaceful feeling.
He just took off.
You forget driving.
It's nice.
Remember when you were a little kid,
you first got your driver's license and you're like,
Woo,
I get to jet.
Not a little kid,
but you know,
18 whatever you first get to.
Do you remember magic four year olds were driving like driving is fun.
Like my six year old,
she's learning how to ride a bike.
So I'm teaching her to ride a bike without training.
Wheels are moving around,
showing her do tight turns and stuff,
and she's having the time of her life.
And I'm thinking if I had to drive a bike in this little fucking ass driveway,
I would be so bored.
But to a six year old,
it's like,
Woo,
it's so fun.
That's what it's like when you first start driving the car.
It's fun and you forget like driving a car.
Just it's a pleasure.
If you have a car that works right and you're out on a nice road and there's no
one there.
Oh Jeez.
Google.
A beautiful view of beautiful view to look out at.
That's the thing that really gets me about Colorado more than anything is the
sheer beauty of the landscape boulder.
Like how about evergreen?
When you're driving from evergreen down into Denver,
people will know about evergreen,
evergreen I half an hour outside of Denver.
You see those green trees like that.
You might as well be on that mountain men TV show.
You might as well be one of those fucking dudes that makes their own.
Would you?
You're up there in the middle of the fucking mountain.
30 minutes from Denver.
Beautiful.
I remember the last time I had peace of mind was I was shooting the longest yard
and I was off on Saturdays and Sundays and they opted,
they said,
you can to go home and stay.
I would stay in the hotel,
the hotel BMV it'd be a couple of us that would stay down there and I would get
the rental car dog and I would get on that road.
I go to Taos.
Oh yeah.
I drive to all those places.
I stopped get a Green Chili,
all hippies.
I turned the fucking car around three,
four hours,
no traffic,
no traffic.
I just get on there,
whatever road.
I don't know what it was.
Now
you ever do that drive from San Diego to Vegas?
Fuck yeah.
That's a nice drive.
Beautiful drive.
When you go through those weird desert areas and you get to see those,
uh,
I went to the,
the air force base.
I forget which base it is down there,
where the blue angels are.
I did a,
I forgot,
I forget the name of it,
but I had to drive down to San Diego and then from San Diego I had to go across
like quite a while to to get to this air force base where they took me on a
flight with the blue angels and you're driving through these desert areas where
these beautiful rock formations and shit,
it's gorgeous out there.
Just as long as you have ac,
it's fucking gorgeous.
Like seeing the,
the cool rock structures and shit.
It's a pleasure.
You know,
people forget you.
We live here in La and we associate driving with being a pain the ass.
How sad is that?
Sad?
It's like,
it's fucking like,
he like wake up the morning,
your feet like,
fuck,
I've got to go to Holly with a two 30 God dammit.
God fucking dammit.
And you start looking and then you get on the phone.
You just put it on channel five and that telling you got one oh one there's an
accident on the way here,
Bro.
I left my house and fucking 10 20 I should have been here early.
I fucking car flipped on the other side as I was driving.
The people are hanging by their fucking seat belts.
I mean it was that far left when I was in my far left.
Wow.
So I got to see it in three motherfuckers out there.
Fucking cameras with TMC course.
Jesus Christ,
Joe Rogan.
That's,
that's justifiable homicide where I come from.
But it's just to shoot him right that pull over what is wrong with you.
If somebody is yelling for their life and you have your fucking camera on you.
Miserable motherfucker.
And there was people getting out of their cars helping them.
I mean it was bumper to bumper.
I don't know how to fucking ambulance.
Just going to get in.
Yeah.
Well that's sometimes,
but welcome to the fucking world to canvas my friends.
Yeah.
Cheat.
Somebody is yelling for their life.
You're going to fucking camera on for a love of Christ.
What kind of God damn human being are you?
I just to extend your hand for the person to see your hand.
You know what's fucked up though.
You talk to them and they're nice guys.
Look a lot of those TMZ camera guys thought it was guys are very nice guy.
I don't even know if it was a TMZ guy.
They were three people.
There was two people with cell phones and the guy had like a little fucking
damn.
I was like,
well,
some people are just filming it because they're there and they had to have,
I mean some people,
if they have something on them that can record,
they have to record things.
Oh my God,
I can't believe it's when we get this on video.
But there's a lot of these guys are just guys who have a job.
It's the real problem is that people want to read that shit.
You know?
That's the real problem,
including us.
It's compelling.
You find out about some crazy story.
It's some nasty shit happen.
TMZ has a video of it.
You don't go to it ever.
No.
TMZ,
if it was used to watch it two,
three years ago,
so six o'clock now,
I just watched the news.
If there's something,
something fucking completely crazy happens,
you're going to,
you know,
people are gonna want to see it.
They're going to want to see a video.
What's a sub with snoop?
Whatever got knocked out.
I was curious.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The Valet guy knocked the man.
I'm a record producer.
Uh,
you know,
not puff Daddy,
but the guy from the west coast rap.
We always talk about shook night.
Sorry.
Yeah,
Barbara knocked him out,
right?
Some,
some do two in the barbershop in La.
But he was a valet,
right?
I don't think so.
I think it was out value.
Yeah.
Oh,
out of valley.
Okay.
I don't remember exactly what happened,
but yeah.
Yeah.
We live in a weird world.
See those videos all the time.
Every day.
There's new ones.
Have you did is,
it's some new thing.
Jamie watches all that shit.
Every time I come in here,
this motherfucker's got some new Beyonce story for me.
I always find that late.
Like I found out about the Tei,
what happened with,
oh,
the Mayweather.
I never saw that,
but that would be assessed the videos online,
you know,
tea.
I went on opie Anthony on for that.
It was fucking hilarious.
It's really funny.
It's like a real relaxed dude.
He's a fun dude.
It was interesting to listen to.
I Dunno.
I just,
I mean,
I don't even know if the video or the appearance on opiate Anthony was after
that fight.
I was just in my car and they were talking and you know,
you look at the serious,
it shows you who the guest is and it said t it was fun.
It's fun guy,
man.
Looks like he's having a good time with them.
Can you get busted with guts?
Yes.
He's looks like a fun guy.
He did a movie.
He did American fucking gangster.
He was an American gangster.
Yeah,
he's the bass,
but Denzel Washington,
he's the one that was the baseball player that he got him a track with.
The Yankees is show up.
It goes up to,
he goes,
how can we didn't show up.
He goes,
I have,
why am I going to play baseball for?
I won't be like,
oh,
that's funny.
Did you see the ads for the new James Brown movie?
They got a James Brown movie who's playing days,
Bro.
I don't know.
Some dude,
Here.
Let's pull it up.
Brown movie.
Uh,
I went to see the Tom Cruise movie last night.
Tomorrow.
It's fucking great.
That movie is Great.
It's really good,
man.
It's called get on up.
Get up.
Park.
Get on up.
The dude's name is Chadwick Bozeman.
Hmm.
I don't know who that is.
Do you know who that is?
Chadwick.
Bozeman.
Okay.
Handsome Fella.
Been at a bunch of shit.
He's been,
he was on all my children.
No Way.
It's just 1970.
It must be a different guy.
James Brown,
the movie comes up.
Chadwick Bozeman.
It came out.
It can't be,
it says all my children.
1970.
It's gotta be a different Chadwick.
Bowman.
You'd dummies.
That doesn't make any sense.
The guys,
he's not that old.
Maybe it was a kid on the shutter.
No,
he's not.
Even that would mean you'd have to be what?
40 something years old?
No Way.
So the movie came out already?
Uh,
no,
no.
It's not out yet.
It's a,
the,
the ads for it right now.
He was in that movie 42 he played Jackie Roberts.
Oh,
that dude's bad ass.
Okay.
Yeah.
That was a good movie though.
I heard it was really good.
It was good.
He was very good.
You know what was good in that movie?
You know who was fucking bad ass who we thought Harrison fucking forward.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
He was the skies.
Harrison Ford.
He said some shit that you're like,
look at fucking Harrison Ford selling.
It isn't interesting.
This dude's plant two famous dead black dudes like Jackie Robinson and then he's
there.
Goto guide dog.
You need a shirt.
Sag Insurance is a motherfucker.
You know what I'm saying?
You got to do with your guts to do sometimes.
Get up that fucking Tom cruise movie is good man.
I'm telling you.
It's one of the most original science fiction movies I've ever seen.
It's really,
I had low expectations.
I went into it.
I thought it was going to be some shooting.
My upward.
Tom Cruise does a standard shit and every one of them is standard,
you know,
like calm,
cool,
collected,
you know,
facing the adversity.
No,
it was a complex character that he had a play and the movie was very complex.
It was.
There was a lot going on.
It was like about time travel.
That was part of the movie is an alien movie,
an alien invasion movie about time travel.
I can't tell you anymore.
I'll give you a spoiler alert,
but it's fucking good.
Movie Man is a good fucking movie.
Like I'd give it a nine out of 10 is a really good movie.
Like one of the most original science fiction movies I've ever seen.
You see it in three d?
No,
no.
I just taught regular.
I'm only wearing glasses.
I'll give you see the movie king of New York.
Yeah.
All right.
Fuck yeah,
great movement.
But a year ago for walking Casa t ray,
this dude on Twitter,
Tobin,
I'm like,
fuck,
that movie's overrated.
This fuck.
It was
holy Shit Joe Rogan.
But to me he didn't do,
I mean Christopher Walkers always Christopher Walken,
right?
Laurence Fishburne stole that motherfucker.
Laurence Fishburne
stole that motherfucker.
Listen,
I come loosen that.
He's the best black actor now and I'll prove it to you.
You know when the,
when he beats the chicken,
the movie Tina Turner,
he plays a different type of black dude.
Don't make me say it.
And then whatever,
he plays a completely different type of black dude.
But the opening of that movie,
he goes to [inaudible] house to buy the coke with Steve was Chevy and Steve was
shammies uh,
uh,
what do you call that shit?
Weighing out the coke,
making sure it's good and fucking Laurence Fishburne is torturing this drug
deal.
Yo,
you play ball not and not by looking at you.
You've got a coke and he keeps torturing him,
torture him.
And then finally the guy,
you want the fucking drugs,
you fucking black guy,
I don't do business.
And it gives him the thing and the guy's about to open up the briefcase,
the check the money and he fucking slams.
And he goes,
where's my mother fucking coke?
Which is classic.
And he finally opens it up and this all tampons.
And he goes,
what the fuck is this to plug your mother fucking holes?
And he shoots him in.
The black guy comes through room service and they started shooting people.
That's the best opening any fucking movie I've seen.
I forgot all about that more.
I sat there going,
what the fuck is this?
Tremendous.
I recommend,
if you haven't seen in a long time,
Christopher Walken.
Well,
you know what you said in that movie dog,
the black dude from lost,
he's the kid on the elevator that goes to Mug Christopher Walken,
me,
Christopher Walken throws him like 10,000 and goes,
come see me,
I'll give you a job.
They look at the money they take off.
That's the little black dude from the launch.
That was also these thousand things.
It was a young kid.
Really like a young kid,
like you know,
2018,
no shit.
It's amazing when you see these old movies and you're like,
wow,
look what the fuck that is playing one scene like in the thief Manhunter that
dude that was CSI for 18 years.
It was on a,
the dude from loss was on,
um,
he was on the fucking,
uh,
the prison,
the Prison Oz.
He was in Oz was too.
Yeah.
The guy in the wheelchair.
That dude's
been around.
You look at these guys go.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
How about Laurence Fishburne?
It was in fucking apocalypse now.
I talked to him one day before they were fucking weed store.
No Shit.
He was talking to me about how he was 14 and he would bring his mother down
there cause they shot that in the Philippines.
They were there for a year,
Bro.
Wow.
He was a kid and I that boat,
he was 14 years old,
15 years old.
He was a fucking child.
He was really young and that movie took a long time to fill.
Two years too.
That's where the studios were just at.
Marlon Brando was on that.
So Marlon Brando,
this is what this motherfucker did.
They met with them.
They're like,
mom,
we love you but get it together.
You're a little getting a little heavy.
You're playing a fucking major.
You're playing a guy who parachutes out of plates.
Please work out how much the trailer caught you.
Give him a check for the train.
What do they want?
10,000 give a 20 get the best train to lose the weight.
Mauler took the check.
Absolutely thought post time that motherfucker showed up,
20 pounds overweight.
And when he was at the meeting,
they were furious.
That's why all the seeds that dark,
that's why the only show his head and shit holding his head.
They never showed his body.
That's why.
Cause they were like,
fuck what the fuck.
We gave you money for a train,
a dog.
I spent the money at spa goes,
you know what I'm saying?
How did we have an island at one point in time when he shot,
listen,
if you're into this shit cause I'm into stupidity.
Okay.
Me and Joe Rogan,
Chase Coburn and sunset boulevard.
I meant to those old actors,
they represented something different.
They represent and Marlon Brando represented something completely different in
my eyes.
This kid was from Nebraska.
This kid was from fucking Nebraska.
You know everybody's stuck on James Deane,
focus off fucking brand.
This guy came out here and just fuck people up.
And they hated him.
They hated him.
You know
Rhoda,
hilarious fucking letter to Charlie Sheen when he couldn't make his birthday
party,
he wrote,
Dear Charlie,
I'm feeling like a very large Turd on a very thin stick.
I'm holed up in bed and taking everything from sled dog urine to power.
Ade Power,
Power D.
I dunno.
Eastern Indian Vulva maybe won't work tomorrow if I feel the same.
That's what he sent him when he was thinking about not going to his party
who was out there.
They didn't want all for the Godfather.
You know how I a push for him for the Godfather,
I use crazy.
He didn't give a fuck.
What the fuck?
And then he showed up.
They know who the fuck he was.
He put the cotton in his mouth,
this shit.
And he just blew him out of the water that that gave him?
No.
Before that they gave him,
what's that movie that we cost the studio 80,000 he was directly a whatever the
fuck about the boat.
And they went down and they realized they get that and they're like,
where's my brand though?
He said the hot fucking six fucking Hawaiian chicks.
That's what he married the check
and he was a crazy motherfuckers.
Crazy mother fucker.
Then he came back dog and he just,
he then he,
he's sent that Indian,
so the fucking Oscars to protest the fucking American movies does this shit and
at the end of his life he didn't he live,
I mean he lived on an island or something.
Right.
Did he do something like that?
I think he lived in studio city.
I sweat.
Yeah,
he lived around here.
Yeah.
He lived around here at the end of the island.
He lost the island.
Okay.
That,
but that was also a tragic side.
He lost his kids.
It was very sad.
That whole thing would happen,
but well,
you can imagine the guy looked that would be really good at taking care of kids.
You know what?
He was really bad at it.
Acid.
I didn't realize it because I didn't listen.
I have to watch it because my wife watches the man of steel.
Oh,
that movie.
Yeah.
Movie.
But I look Kevin Crow,
but
okay.
Not Good.
Marlon Brando cemented that role.
Soul Straw.
That speech.
He tells him before he puts them in the fucking thing,
bro.
Yeah.
That's what had to be Super Mad.
If your father tells you to speech,
if your father look Shinier,
I told you that speech,
you've got to be superman.
That's it.
You're like that.
You just blew my fucking mind.
It was amazing.
And we had a lease of an island.
Yeah.
1966.
He got a 99 year lease.
The island of this,
I don't know how to say this is t e T.
I n.
A R O,
a Ted [inaudible] row by uh,
Tahiti government making him it's sole owner,
35 miles from the main island of Tahiti.
It's a group of 13,
uh,
Islet Small Islands measuring about 27 square miles and surrounded by a lagoon.
Fucking dude lived up there on an eco resort.
Wow.
Crazy man.
Yeah.
Strange,
strange dude,
man.
You know there's a roommate used to charge to read your script.
He used to charge you to read your script.
Like if you go a studio,
say hi Marla,
we have a script for you.
Okay.
50 g's.
He would bang you at every level.
That makes sense though.
If you're Marlon fucking Brando,
you know,
25 to read the script.
Do you want me to come off the island for a meeting?
I'm gonna have Herbie call you right on that one.
That's when you're a bad mother fucker.
When they're willing to fly into an island to talk to,
and if you want it to fly him off,
it will be you like triple to fly him off the island.
Yeah.
Like,
oh no,
we want you to come to Hollywood
to show up with this crazy hat on.
What do we have here for this group of 600 pounds,
400 pounds?
Apparently he would sign up to do movies to hadn't read it at all and would make
them put up these big placards with all the lines that he had to say like right
behind them.
As we end,
we just free ball it on the side.
I don't,
uh,
I think that the Americans,
I think people itself sometimes take to
sacredly,
you know,
but if like in the Godfather,
the scene where he's at the table,
he's talking about if something should happen to my son and he gets up,
that's what they said he was reading off.
The guys are,
pals is shit.
But look at them.
See if you see him really at the end.
Maybe like 1972 when he was dropping the gun.
The Godfather has been on HBO this month,
eight 30 in the morning.
You know what I mean?
I get up at six.
I'm watching the news all or sudden the Godfather,
I gotta catch 10 minutes of it.
Last night.
I watched the scene when the,
he told,
what's his name,
he was out.
He was brilliant,
Bro.
He told,
uh,
the constantly,
I read the White Dude,
he tells him,
he goes,
we're going to Vegas.
He just got out of the hospital and he goes,
you know,
you're any smacks me goes,
no offense.
Let Michael,
I'm going to do this.
And he goes,
but I can help you.
And Michael Goes,
you're out.
He gets up and leaves.
He's beautiful,
Bro.
He's beautiful.
So no matter if he was reading cards and Shit,
you know,
we forget.
You forget bro.
You if we forget because we were subjected to such bad fucking movies.
But I watched that movie again,
the idea,
and I'd been watching pieces.
I don't have the time to sit and watch three hours,
but it's been on HBO.
And I watched the scene where he comes down,
he tells Duval cars are coming to my house,
telling you to do vowels.
Another one was great,
you know,
tell you don what everybody seems to know.
And he goes,
oh,
I was about to,
but you had to have a drink.
Takes a drink out of his hand.
[inaudible] he goes,
now you're adjunct drink.
I get goosebumps.
I've seen that seen a hundred times.
I still get goosebumps.
Sproul.
Well,
he looks at sunny.
He throws that curtain down on that table and he tells that,
dude,
look how they massacred my son.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you fucking kidding me yet?
Go ahead.
Get the guy from Anglican gangs in New York,
he'll take that guy and break them and fucking hat by his neck like a j.
At that time,
that dude was dropping it on you with cue cards,
with whatever.
It didn't matter.
He knew who the fuck he was in a way in there.
You know what's interesting man is,
hey did last tango in Paris.
That's what's interesting.
There isn't a Porto after that and they really last tango in Paris.
Look at this homework for that.
Yeah,
it was porno.
Why do you say as a porn,
it was this close to Portland as could be that they really look at the,
look at the poster for it.
I'm looking at it every second,
nine and a half weeks kind of porn.
Yeah,
it's him and some broad I'm making out and this thing,
Italian American Franco Italian romantic or erotic drama.
Wow.
I never saw that.
Yeah,
he's crazy.
That too.
He puts light bulbs in a pussy,
white water and shit.
Ball snap like vinegarette the original battery
trader.
Recent American widower who begins and anonymous sexual relationship with a
young Betroth,
Prezi and woman,
Marlon Brando,
Maria Shriver,
Schneider.
Who's Maria Schneider
still alive,
alive and kicking.
Nope.
Died.
58 2011 in Patty died in [inaudible] 58 is not that old.
Wow.
You know,
it's interesting.
I was going to say that some movies like the godfather holds up perfect.
The Godfather could be in the movies today.
It would seem a little unusual because of the way it's Sorta filmed and framed
and the music in it and everything like that.
It would it be like,
it would stand out as being unusual,
but it would totally hold up.
But other movies from that era,
big movies that you really enjoyed from that era dog,
a French connection.
You want to shoot yourself.
It's really bad except for the
why would he shakes everybody down,
Bob by doors.
Hey,
what the fuck is this?
And it makes the milkshake.
Yeah,
that's all really good.
But everything else that mechanic drags and Charles Bronson movie want to shoot
yourself.
Really?
It's brutal.
Even hot high times holds up,
you know,
high mechanic at slow.
She tried to watch the Godfather.
I never watched any of them.
It's
slow.
The mechanic,
you got to have balls of steel.
Your wife,
no,
she's just don't look at jam.
Michael Vessel Thai for about 20 minutes.
But he's an example of a guy who fell apart.
America doesn't know the beauty of a man because member of Jab,
Michael Vincent,
it kept it together.
Richard Gere would've still been jumping down with fucking Hindus and fucking
Baghdad or wherever the fuck he was.
He's a Buddhist,
Richard Gere.
Big Time.
There would've been no Richard Gere cause he was blind.
He was about to kill it.
He killed it with the world's greatest athlete.
Maybe when we were kids and Disney,
he picked up the fucking weights and his army stayed there and shit.
He was that he played.
Uh,
but that was all,
he played a movie called defiance,
where he's a longshoreman on the west side with Paulie walnuts and the Sopranos.
Danny Aiello.
And they attack a fucking,
uh,
a gang,
like a Mexican Puerto Rican gang.
That movie was on HBO for a while,
but that movie,
that mechanic is slow as fuck.
Then they go to elite.
That slow as fuck through when they go to Italy.
He was born in Denver,
Colorado,
and he's still alive.
Jan Michael Vincent is still alive.
That's amazing.
69 years old.
No fucking kidneys.
Your liver.
That motherfuckers just knit crazy though.
Last tango in Paris.
Chick Dennis.
Fuck Sham.
Mako Vincent pickled drunk as shit though.
Teeth they'll kick in.
Yeah,
man.
He's fucking,
apparently he's got some issues too.
He left Hollywood 12 years ago for a life on the Mississippi Delta.
That's where he lives now.
God's gotta be a weird ride,
man.
Not Everybody's cut out for that kind of movie star Tom Cruise Type Shit.
It's crazy as that Tom Cruise motherfucker is,
keeps it together.
Pretty God damn good.
I mean,
I'm sure if you talked to one of his ex wives,
they would say,
Ooh,
that would tell you some horror story.
What people and fucking crazy outfits,
you know,
tell him about Xenu up on the planet.
Pluton or some shit.
It's controlling Tom's vibrations.
Forcing him to recite the doctrine of Scientology.
But if you look at it like what he's done and the fact that he's still alive and
kicking from,
go back to like,
what was that first movie?
Uh,
just take those old records.
Ah,
Shit.
What movie was that risky business go from risky business to today in 2000 and
fucking 14 Tom Cruise is still knocking it out of the park as a movie star.
You know why Gyro Scientology?
No,
just decide side tachy he's as well prepared as you are his gaze on top of his
game.
You know that you can't be fucking around and getting 20 million of move you
fucking around.
He's on top of his game.
You know what bro?
He's got some movies that you watch them and go,
yeah,
this sucks,
but gold.
Yeah.
He went from risky business and all of a sudden he rocked,
I guess Jack Nicholson of that movie with the marine movie.
What's the name of that fucking movie?
Oh yeah.
If you could meet whatever.
He rocked her that and then he rocked this fucking Jerry Maguire.
I mean,
he hit it out of the fucking park as an agent.
But dog,
when you watch that fucking movie where he plays the Hitman with Jamie Foxx.
Oh yeah.
He goes into the Japanese bar.
It was Korea town and he starts shooting motherfuckers looking at his legs,
but he shoots,
that's the middle of stairs.
That's military style shooting.
And you just don't make that up.
You,
you're a scientologist.
So that means for three weeks before that,
he went and worked somewhere.
He was beautiful.
That movie.
And that scene at all
guys who've ever done those movies,
he's the most consistent.
Like he does his own stunts is on race,
rolling stones,
all that shit.
And you know what?
I'm [inaudible] at tight.
He's a tiny dude.
Ricky Cruz play this double,
uh,
the movie where he said that was horrendously bad Santa movie.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
the sunset strip.
When we played a Rockstar,
Alec Baldwin and all those people
I heard that was a hunk of shit.
Oh,
they said it was the kiss at that Ricky cruise played his double is a standard.
[inaudible] he's not,
I heard it's an exaggeration,
but it's not that tiny.
I heard that they actually build sets where it's bigger so he can stand on site.
Whoever he with it.
Well they did that with him and Brad Pitt when him and Brad Pitt did interview
with the vampire.
Brad Pitt talked about how they would walk and Tom Cruise would walk next to him
on like a ramp.
So like Brad Pitt would walk here and Tom Cruise would walk next to him on a
ramp because he had to be the same height as him.
I bet they do that for a lot of movies though.
Cause they have these leads that he like the actresses,
they can't have the actress be taller than him.
So,
oh
that's weird.
It's weird.
It's weird that that hasn't like it's hampered him,
you know,
in any way.
He's still like one of the main movie stars.
He rocks the house,
rocks the house.
He rocked house and this,
I'm telling you,
Joey,
go see this guy.
Yeah,
you don't have to solve it.
But there's some people we love this,
the,
a lot of the capitol,
and this helped me in that.
That's another got to give a big envelope too.
He's crazy.
Does it?
He does it to get that big envelope he's got,
yeah,
he's going to do dog shirts,
Bro.
You can't control that.
Ca calls him guess while we have a movie about a bar,
you're going to be great.
And next thing you know he's tap dancing.
I'm sure why they giving them envelopes.
It's okay after he goes to the fucking screen.
Five,
see he's five,
seven and ving.
Rhames is actually six foot,
but this isn't a good example where they're trying to make him look.
I don't think he's five seven.
I think that's a lie.
I think that's one of those Napoleon things.
You know,
everybody talks about Napoleon being short.
You know the Polian was like above average height for the time.
It wasn't short.
It was England fucking with them.
They would do all these jokes about Napoleon being short.
He was five,
six back then people were tiny shit.
So like five,
six back then was like a normal size dude.
Is this the same website you keep pulling up college humor?
I don't know if they substantiated that.
All the other websites also said five seven
five seven here's the key.
Here's the point when time couriers.
Yup.
Five seven Diaz is five seven see how they're making him like they're
constantly,
always make him tell her,
even though these people are way taller than him.
Oh,
so he's standing on something.
Yeah,
like buckets and stuff.
Yeah.
It says a,
wouldn't it be funny if he's actually six feet tall,
but this is just a giant troll that everybody's saying.
He's five seven,
five,
seven,
seven.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's walking next to people.
Well,
Katie Holmes was giant.
Like where they would go out in public.
Katie Holmes was like legitimately like five 10 right?
Wasn't she?
No,
I think she's Kinda young girl or girl.
Oh,
she is?
She's five.
Nine.
Yeah,
but so it was Nicole Kidman.
Nicole.
Kim was big too.
I'll say what's going on there?
He's,
yeah.
He's not doing it to got some shit in his shoes.
Well,
there's dudes who were stuff in their shoes,
you know,
and she's got,
Raj is big too,
right?
Yeah.
Maybe we Rogers Rogers,
he slept some deck though.
Maybe he did.
Maybe,
you know,
whatever he did,
he figured out how to get all these girls to marry him.
This,
you know what,
we'll never get the full story because Scientology is so secretive and inclusive
and you know,
so,
so culty but what a fascinating story that would be,
let's see,
like if,
if,
I mean if the rumors are all true,
if he really is a closeted gay guy that has arranged marriages and they go on
for 10 years and the women get all this money and you know,
he needs them because this is like the image that he's trying to,
to portray that.
It's a fascinating story.
I've
explained to them,
cause I was thinking about it and look at what happened with Donald Sterling.
How would he meetings,
could you go to and say to yourself,
I can make a fucking kill me if I could get my phone to take a meeting of,
you know,
seeing like a Scientology party would.
It really is.
It's like a vault and fucking Tom cruise jumper up on some guys working on it
was somebody would sell that for hundred million dollars.
That's one a though.
Well,
you know,
you're
seeing that now with certain guys like this Brian Singer guy that directs the x
men that this is the guy that is in trouble because one of his ex boyfriends is
claiming that he was sexually exploited and they pass them around.
If you paid attention to this,
Holy Shit.
They have fucking parties.
Let me tell you something.
No hate gay motherfuckers know how to partner.
They know how to party.
These guys have this fucking day as photos.
Pull up some photos of Brian Singer's parties.
He has parties where he has a red lights in the swimming pool and they were
filled with twinks.
It's a twink soup and everyone is dancing around the pool.
The pool is,
it's flooded by guys with no shirts on and they're all touching each other and
having a great fucking time.
And if you're gay that God,
that's gotta be the way.
Look at this.
That's the way to fucking party.
Why not?
What is everybody angry at?
What's Twix twinks twinks or like little skinny gay guys that look,
you know,
kind of like boyish.
That's,
that's a type,
yeah,
super twink and he just gives a super twain,
but like,
look at this.
What is wrong with this?
This looks like a super positive scene to me.
I don't have any problem with anything I see here.
I see a bunch of guys doing what they want to do their pants off.
They're hanging around in a pool.
Who gives a shit?
The water brown.
No,
that's
from all that ass to go light blue lives.
Don't do it as a light in the pool lights.
You've seen the corner,
you see the red light.
It's obvious there's lights.
Is it red light bulbs with the guy,
Bryan singer.
He's been around for a while.
Yeah.
What kind of movies directed before?
Right.
Directed a lot of movies.
Like what?
Like x men did a lot of extra time two years ago.
Right now he's done it.
I think he's got quite a few of them right?
It hasn't he,
he's done a bunch of shit.
Let's do Brian saying let's pull it up like that one guy that was suing because
he's getting me,
cause he was like the guy that got passed around by all the guys.
But you know what man,
here's the deal.
If you show up for one of those things and you got passed around,
you're like,
what the hell?
I gotta get Outta here.
This is a bad situation.
If you keep showing up and you keep getting passed around and then you want to
write a book about it,
you could have left.
I know what time it is.
You got a coast Costar Pot.
You got fucked in the ass 82 times.
That's it.
Listen,
I could see that happening in Hollywood.
It happens to women all the time,
guys.
They go to these fucking parties.
I don't know what type of parties there are next to the other.
In the Hollywood hills that do with fucking Ruffino.
They're doing blow and there's eight fucking young guys.
Fucking,
it happens kind of.
I've been to one.
No,
it happens.
It has to happen with little young guys for the confused here.
They come from a small town that gay,
they go to an audition,
Bryan singer contacts about what the 12th you personally,
you know,
let's do lunch.
Next thing you know,
you read a fucking pool and let's go.
Let's go upstairs.
Probably can't even believe it.
You know,
you watch that movie with Tom Cruise,
one of the darkest movies he made great movie.
Which movie you want without the masks.
That's always on late night.
Why Saint Bryan singer?
Because W I compare
that situation to like that.
Yeah,
that Stanley Kubrick,
but we're a bunch of old guys.
They're fucking,
once a month they go to a house.
Red Band tells me to call a phone and say red devil.
And He sends you to a house and it was a car picks you up.
You don't even know where you're going,
how fucking creepy.
And they take it to a house and there's a fucking hundred tenge walking around
with mascot naked,
naked.
And you're doing the sacrilegious shit with drums,
with a robot,
which means you're going to fuck somebody in the ass till they die then.
But Tom Cruise was fucking a chick and she was on coke and she took her in.
The doctor was Sydney Pollack.
Nobody fucking remembers here.
What do you remember that movie at all?
That's a fucking dark man.
What happened bro?
What happens is the coke Kidman fucks with him.
Let me tell you some,
I never thought Nicole came and was shit that I watched that movie the coke him
and eat him up and spits them alive.
Like with this accent.
She starts to tell him about it once was a time where I went to this thing with
this army guy and he,
he,
you were in a man,
like he starts telling him he wasn't a man,
but that she went in this guy that got a navy guy.
So he got so mad,
he started getting a cab and he kept seeing spots of this fucking guy just
rammed with Nicole Kidman,
black and white footage in your head of this guy with a navy hat.
Just blasted it.
And finally he goes to get a hooker.
She's missing something.
So he goes into an Arabian,
this dude to get a,
because he goes to see his buddy who was the piano play and the guy goes,
no,
I gotta,
I got a Gig I can't tell you about.
He tells me about the Gig.
He goes,
you got to wear a cape and a top hat.
So this dude has to go to a fucking costume store at midnight,
wakes up the guy.
But when he wakes up the guy to rent the costume,
they hear something and they go in the room and the guy,
that costume guy has a daughter who's 15 and she's getting fucked by two
Japanese guys,
wear wigs and Mascara on and pink shit on their faces.
This is darker than fuck.
And Tom Cruise walks in the middle of this and pop them on off.
So he's like,
what the fuck's going on?
And he takes a cab to this place.
It gives the cap 200 bucks and he walks in and he sees all these naked woman.
He tells him the code word and I mean it's fucking God.
He goes in there and Sydney Pollack.
Then the next day he goes looking for the piano guy and the piano guys missing
God because they go up to Tom Cruise during the thing and they go,
we know who you are.
We're advise you to get that.
A lot of here.
The next set of piano play is gone done.
Finito he goes back to the costume store,
he returned to stuff.
One thing leads to another guy goes,
oh no,
you're missing the boat time and all of a sudden after all the yelling and
screaming,
when she caught the fucking guy with the Japanese guys,
the girl comes walking out of the back where the two Japanese guys wear business
suits on.
So he thinks he's going to fucking,
it's an awesome mindfuck.
If you could sit it out,
Stanley Kubrick was was a bad motherfucker.
That movie took like three years to release.
There was something about movie Kubrick was
dying,
but Nicole Kidman,
it wears a pair of regular panties with a wife beater with those little teddies
dog.
When I mean with little teddies turning you on when those two little beavers are
up and she's calling them like a fucking faggot through his face,
he's like,
you're a fucking faggot.
I dream of this navy guy fucking taking me down and breathing on my neck.
I could smell his breath and he's like breaking inside and it goes really well.
I'm going to go out and slate some days.
He's a doctor in the movie.
There she is right there.
Look it up.
Little teddies that say,
get up and fucking come on these little fucking milk duds.
Look up with that fucking hat.
Bumped up your pull up behind the fucking I get dragged her into the yellow.
Look it up.
Look at that little random fucking with Australian little monkey.
It's mostly like an alligator
fucking savage between her legs.
Look at that.
Look at those little bony hips.
You know how good they fucked when I'm stuck in that fucking monster.
Well those hips up popping up.
Forget about Wednesday,
11 o'clock.
That check is bagging.
I need to get that on my iPad tonight.
That's why I shot.
I probably need to rewatch cause I remember I didn't like it the first time I
watched it.
But every woman in that and that scene and then he does blow with the check or
she knows blow you Britton and Stanley.
That motherfuckers crazy.
He said they Apollo.
You know,
he was like she's dead or some shit or whatever.
I'm a doctor.
What's wrong with you?
You're losing it.
It didn't get a good good review.
No.
Cause it was Stanley.
You know it was dark dog.
They'd say what?
What a Stanley's other movies real quick.
2001 a space odyssey space,
but he's got another one that's crazy orange.
She's got it.
Yeah.
And they're all fucking fuck movies.
But what's another Stanley like an army movie that didn't have a dark.
Yeah,
full metal jacket.
That's a shit.
Okay.
That's fucking dark shit.
Brilliant.
What is it that,
that's a brilliant move.
Jelly donut Colbert pile.
You know that's the best army movie ever talked when he saw metal jacket.
Is there a better army movie?
Apocalypse now was up there too.
It's up there.
But I think full metal jackets better.
I think it might be better efficient bro.
It's right up their platoon.
That's up their tents up there too.
But I'm saving private.
Ryan is up there too.
That opening scene,
man,
fucking hit that beat.
That is as real as a fucking war scene gets.
There's no heart was beating up a fucking store and that fucking,
you know movie isn't bad when I watch it.
What's the one with down whatever Black Hawk down.
Never saw it.
That's great.
Maybe you've never seen Black Hawk down.
Don't tell me it's not.
Listen Bro.
To me,
that fucking opening scene with Martin Sheen and apocalypse now and what he's
directing it and he's like,
I'm waiting for a minute that I've been gone.
I went to see that movie on double barrel,
so I just tried acid with John Crowley,
dd Conterra and current dealer ran.
So we were out there waiting to go in and there was a Carvel and next to the
place,
I'll never forget this,
Joe Rogan.
I was tripping my balls off and there was a Carvel.
Next is movie theater.
There was a,
it was the second,
it was a midnight showing an apocalypse now.
Yeah,
just come out on Friday.
It was a bin night.
We were in high school.
It's midnight on double barrel,
sunshine acid burden burden.
When your eyes a burden,
you're seeing shit and we'll wait.
Now lie,
there's an ice cream cone that's tipped over that somebody went to the movie
theater and tip it over and on it and my friend John Crowley picked it up and
study.
I thought I was going to fucking die and they were waiting for the midnight
showing it's 16 years old,
whatever the fuck I was and watched apocalypse now and acid.
I thought it was going to fucking die and go to that scene where they start
shooting arrows at them out of the fucking world and that's not the movie.
I don't sleep on that and forget the redux.
I liked the reduction.
They show up in France and eat with the people.
That's okay,
but it takes you away from the fucking path.
I liked the what they released because it's straight.
The redux is good for a little while.
The body is the French guy.
They all have dinner at that table,
but I really liked the fucking original.
These are like the redux cause he's just got some added extra,
I don't want it.
It's three and a half hours.
I got that little extra something.
It's not what you need though.
It's not what you need.
That movie had they cut that movie a certain fucking away.
The movie was creepy Bro.
It was creepy.
There was parts of that movie where you feel creaked the fuck out.
You know what else I saw a couple of weeks ago that you haven't,
Saint Joe Rogan midnight express great fucking movie when he bites that
motherfucker's tongues out your shit and he's standing there and he's covered in
fucking blood and the Oh fucking tremendous.
I think just that was the first time I ever saw a movie where a guy got arrested
in another country and I was like,
Oh,
don't get arrested in another country,
especially for drugs.
Oh my God.
When they took his clothes down and he had the envelope stuck to his body,
you feel it.
Your heart's beating because the director
Tony,
he's got his hands up and I was of like,
oh.
And he's got the guns all around them and they take them in and they don't pip
the deep.
Yeah,
somebody fuck that.
He became game.
That became,
it became [inaudible] and then that's where the guy kept fucking with them and
the guy hung has Fred's cat.
And once he woke up and seen the cat hanging,
the guy went nuts because you try just for fucked up to on sellers hash and he
just starts beat.
That's one of the greatest beats of all time.
Maybe he's kicking them.
The guys under the sink crawling.
He's bleeding,
he's begging for his life and he's just fucking loser.
He's been in this fucking foreign country.
He's been lied to.
They gave 80 years.
You're dying and I'm dying to,
and he's kicking.
He's kicking checkup and finally got claws out.
He's got like one I left.
He fucking grabs him and he fucked.
Cause he's a rat.
He fucking mugs upset.
He takes his fucking company,
bites it out and they show the scene with his fucking tongue of this month.
The Guy fucking fall and that guy died.
He died of AIDS in real life.
They got to emulate him.
The guy is brilliant.
He just sits there and you could see the rage.
You could feel it,
bro.
I would go crazy if I was the fucking web of jail.
They had you and now you don't understand the language.
Some guys selling you water down fucking t he rats on yet
and now he killed your friend's cat,
Bro.
He throws a beaten on that guy,
hit him with the pots,
the pans,
and by the time he comes off from the other side,
he's missing an eye and he fucking grabs them.
Just mites is fucking fuck off of being a rat.
Good googly Mowgli.
I was in the fucking hate the seventh grade pro.
That's the movies I watch.
I'm going to fucking ECZEMA.
What are you talking about?
Me fucking movie.
Great Hex man.
That was a movie too.
That taught a lot of kids,
not the fucking smuggle drugs in the country because there's a lot of people
that watch that locked up abroad and they're like,
well,
the guys on TV now,
I guess he got away with it.
Everything's fine.
Most people that got locked up abroad then didn't go so well.
That gave her some watch.
That show terrifying for the show.
I don't even go there.
You don't watch that show?
No.
I don't even want to go to that mentally.
No,
I was never I,
they'll listen.
I don't leave volumes that bad.
I got to cross the border of Mexico trying to bring them over.
Once that happens,
you're gun.
What's Mexico is not nearly as bad crossing from Mexico into America.
That's nothing like that in Turkey.
My fears,
I don't leave.
We'll leave the country with drugs.
Well,
I do drugs.
I don't want to leave this country because I need them.
I don't want to get caught somewhere buying beat him.
I'm sure you want to smoke a joint and fucking Africa,
right?
Yeah.
And who knows what the laws are there?
What's the laws for weed and China?
Right?
The lock you up,
they'll give you 80 fucking ears.
What is already doing over there?
Staying clean.
She's,
I wonder what are you doing for weed?
Yeah.
Yes.
He's definitely staying clean.
Just a clean General Mao or whatever the fuck his name is.
Chairman.
Sure.
What did they give you for weed over there?
Like what type of shit they give you for wheat and China?
Well,
as far as like a sentence.
Yeah,
I'm not good.
It's very bad.
Come on.
Yeah.
Well we didn't.
China's very bad weed.
North Korea is legal and that word was weird.
No drugs bad.
In China,
they have all say the fucking listen to the mob stole the idea from the people
in China.
So I know this selling coke or something.
Not Everybody's going to jail for 80 years and Tryna let me pee real quick.
Drug laws in China,
let's look it up.
Illegal drugs
trade in China.
It's a,
it's a pretty simple,
China has one fifth of the world's population and a large expanding economy.
While OPM has played an important role in the country's history since the
beginning.
Oh,
since before.
Okay.
Though the first and second opium wars,
the 19th century,
China's large lab,
Matt,
loud,
large,
landmass,
cross close proximity to the Golden Triangle and numerous coastal cities with
large and modern port facilities make it an attractive transit center for drug
trafficking.
Hmm.
What is the fucking opium war?
Awesome.
Let's go.
Sounds like a good movie.
The first opium war.
Okay,
let's find out about the opium war.
Dan was in the 18 hundreds it was fought between Great Britain and China over
there.
Conflicting viewpoints on diplomatic relations,
trade and the administration of Justice for foreign nationals.
Prior to the conflict,
Chinese officials wished to end the spread of opium and confiscated around
20,000 chests of opium.
Approximately 1.2 million kilograms or two point whatever,
eight,
six,
6 million pounds from British traders.
The British government,
although not officially denying China's right to control inputs of the imports
of the drug,
objected to the seizure and use its military power to enforce violent redress.
So there's two,
two of them.
One of them was in a,
this,
the 18 hundreds there and another one was,
uh,
1856 to 1860.
There's two different opium wars.
Wow.
We don't like it.
They give you,
they give you a lot.
A lot of time.
Let's say
seizures,
treaties and conventions.
Drug laws,
agencies.
Okay,
let's see.
Drug law enforcement.
Yeah.
There's,
it's not good.
Don't do drugs in China.
That's all I remember.
Um,
the Mickey work movie,
it's another fucking under underappreciated movie.
You're the Dragon Chavez.
13.
Any five dog.
That was a great fucking fuck who y'all go.
We won't make money with it.
But the story was about basically what's the Chinese said,
you know what bro?
How long have you bought the fuck is going to be fucking list.
He is,
they can't catch us.
They never have.
You never read about the DEA busted the Chinese smuggling heroin.
Yeah.
Why is that really that really that they'd been doing it since the beginning of,
well,
they still doing it and trying it down.
I don't know.
I don't live there no more.
I heard it's a workout,
but I know when I was growing up,
the Chinese gave it to the black power guys.
The Chinese supplied the Jews,
the disciple of Chinese supplied all the major outlets.
They raped them.
They didn't give him that cut.
They pay them a percentage wholesale and then they went out cut at 18 times and
a $30,000 investment.
He made a half a million dollars,
bro.
Wasn't that a part of that movie with Denzel Washington where his,
his friend was,
was it was,
yeah.
That's what it was.
Wasn't part of it was going to China and well he was taking,
he was bringing it in from Vietnam,
from Vietnam,
Goit,
Liddy.
All those motherfuckers went on it.
All of those motherfuckers where you think they were doing and we think
everybody want to go to talk,
make tours of Vietnam.
They were making,
they were all over that fucking bringing in heroin in body bags pro.
The government do that.
That was the CIA and all those heavy duties.
Right.
That's what she going let he got in trouble.
Well,
you got trouble for Watergate,
but it's knowing that he was over there said that he is back.
Shit,
wasn't it?
Well,
there was so much money when you have so much money with what they,
the,
the amount of money in heroin in the Vietnam,
especially back then there was no Wikipedia,
no Edward Snowden,
no.
Julian Assan is,
you could hide shit pretty fucking easy and there was so much money to be made
in heroin.
Why wouldn't the government make it their,
their,
I think their idea was like,
look,
we'd be crazy.
Like someone's going to make this money and if they make the money,
they're going to control the resources that they get from that money.
They're going to be able to have influence and power and do things to people
with that money.
Fucking leg.
We'll just do it.
We'll do it the right way.
And they just just started selling heroin.
They just started doing it the whole night.
I mean,
that was one of the main reasons why we had a hard time getting out of Vietnam.
The amount of money that was being generated.
Is that the truth?
Oh yeah.
Vietnam and heroin.
It's very well documented.
The Vietnam trade in heroin is a fascinating story because essentially repeating
itself in Afghanistan,
nobody,
everybody buries her head in the sand.
Nobody wants to admit it.
But the Afghanistan poppy trade,
like the,
the amount of heroin grown in Afghanistan is the huge percentage of the world's
heroin,
not just little bit of Afghanistan money,
the world.
Okay.
Let's,
let's look it up.
What do you guess percentage of heroin,
percentage of world heroin grown in Afghanistan?
Take a guess.
What would you think of this?
70%.
Okay.
Percentage of world's heroin in Afghanistan.
Um,
I'm gonna say 90.
Let's see.
Okay,
shut up dude.
let's,
it's fine.
It is to,
to,
to opium production in Afghanistan,
Wikipedia,
uh,
amounts to export value of $4 billion.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
It's wholesale.
Correct?
Well,
I don't think your tax it
well,
that's wholesale selling it to me for it outs or a pal for whatever and be
cutting meat if it's 4 billion wholesale that they're,
the wholesale is,
they grow it,
they process it.
I come over and pick it up.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know.
I don't know how they,
how they work.
It's just amazing.
Okay.
Hmm.
Well,
it's one thing is a fact.
It's,
I'm having a hard time find the numbers.
Well,
one thing is the fact that it's gone up.
They're all saying that it hits record highs despite billions of dollars spent
to combat heroin trade,
Afghanistan,
opium production hits record highs.
This is a 2013 that the United States spent $7 billion to combat opium
production.
So they're there.
They're stealing from both sides.
They spent $7 billion and it went up.
It rose 36%.
Wow.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
60,000 US forces left Afghanistan down from a peak of $100,000.
So what they're saying is essentially,
no matter what they do,
the heroin production keeps going up and weird clerical.
Who's the actor that just died?
Tragically?
Which one?
The guy,
Paul Walker.
Uh,
no,
no.
From heroin.
Phillips.
Oh,
from Maryland.
After Phillip Seymour Hoffman.
They went and they said,
boy,
heroines got to go down to this city.
You know,
some fucking crazy commissioner.
And he would put a cop and they got the guy that sold the bags out and then
probably he rolled on somebody and once he rolled on and somebody that fucking
cop got transferred Ethiopia and the,
that guy got fucking thrown and that's it.
They can't go you.
It's so fucking big.
The heroin trade and what a part of it,
somebody normal doesn't,
would say,
yeah,
we're going to fucking come back at it.
Really,
really fucking heroin prices have gone down 90% of the roads up yet.
Yeah.
99% in 2000 it was 70 heroin is down to like,
you could buy $7 bags of heroin,
bro.
That's $7 $7 I could borrow $7 every fucking day,
guys.
$7 but just how crazy.
That's,
that's not,
but how crazy is it?
The one spot,
90% of the world's supply,
the world is 7 billion people.
How many people do heroin in the world?
The numbers have to be crazy.
When you had it and all these other countries,
not just America.
I didn't Mexico and Canada and everywhere.
The whole world.
Correct.
They processed everyone.
Everyone.
I don't believe so
poppy from there,
they process it.
Mexico cause Mexican heroin is that black car.
It's thick.
You've got to shoot it to shit that you buy in New York.
They have this white stuff.
You could snort it.
Oh really?
Uh,
and they tell you it's for a suburban.
Kids that don't like needles.
Oh.
Slash Norton that.
Listen Bro,
the heroin in New York is a sold to to Spanish people in Puerto Ricans in the
Bronx.
That black people,
that's what the New York trader's role,
the heroin that's sold in New York.
It's the fucking 20 year old yuppies that do a blast.
They do.
They don't shoot it.
They snorted.
That's what a big heroin is.
So yeah,
you still got the old geezers that are fucking shooting and they're fucking
wheel Seymour Hoffman shooting it.
I mean,
yeah.
He or she.
Have you tried this?
Snorting it?
What's the,
uh,
what do you feel?
How do you feel after I've never shot it.
I snorted it right the first time it was,
uh,
I got sick,
I got really pukey and I got sick,
but after I puked,
I felt better and I got really high and the first time I did it was like a pass
out type mode.
Like I,
I was thinking about stuff like,
I was thinking of my,
he was playing music and I was thinking about this stuff.
The second time I did,
I was locked up.
He did it in jail,
the jail and prison at that time I did it.
They came up with dudes,
but I don't know how to get in their visitation that,
ah,
you swap spit.
There was a,
my mouth hit the balloons.
I swap spit with you.
Whoa.
Not me.
I didn't smell it.
And this little girl,
a girl and my wife comes in,
it's you.
It's not worth it.
The the,
uh,
what that one was,
was black tar heroin.
And what the guy did was he cooked and he poured it in my loves of the Syringe,
but none of that wall,
nothing happened,
didn't work.
Then they're saying that 40% more poppies are grown in Mexico than marijuana.
Now they're growing more heroin,
40% more than marijuana.
The problem with the heroin,
the marijuana is that it's legal here,
essentially,
essentially illegal in California and California is right next door.
Forensic is a nice people,
but they can't compete with the fuck is going on in northern California.
They're very nice people.
It's California.
We were there still people in parts of the country that spoke,
that Brown.
We,
that goes to Connecticut,
that goes to Boston,
that goes to Minneapolis.
A lot of brown weed.
There's still a little traffic left in that Brown weed,
but for the most part,
don't take no fucking genius to know.
Listen than fucking yell at kids and Northern California,
they're about to fucking blow up.
The world is doing okay.
Even Amsterdam's like we can't compete on one dam's gone.
People go,
hey,
you ever go to Amsterdam?
Why the fuck would I go to Amsterdam but I can go to Denver gun?
It's all over.
Gentlemen.
Don't believe the hype.
They sh they closed all their stores like my store is done at the end of the
month.
The store next to us,
the end of the month.
What do you mean define wellness?
Went down a home.
My favorite spots or they just shut him down.
Now they went after the landlord ticket in north Hollywood.
Why would they do that?
They gotta pass it just to get it legal like it isn't Denver Denver's making so
much money.
Hand over fist.
They did a CNBC show about it.
You'll see the incredible,
oh boy.
There was a guy who was a weed pen company says in two years is companies going
to be worth $1 billion for a fucking weed?
Pens,
vape pens.
People buy a vape pens with no vape to put it.
Yeah,
just to have been Connecticut,
New York and when you can have some legal,
you get wax down and stuff like that.
You get wax,
you can grind the wheat up.
There's a lot of them.
Then you just grind the wheat up and you pack them,
but you've got to pack them.
Yeah,
like every two or three hits you've got to pay there.
Those are silly,
but they have them.
I like to see what would happen if they take the legal marijuana thing too,
Michigan and tried to see it.
You're not throw it in Detroit.
Yeah,
it's a good move.
But people would get high and then realize why the fuck are we standing in the
first two months ago,
the first two months go to the little kid rock's house.
People could be getting robbed on the way up.
Yes.
That's the probably going to happen.
Detroit,
they going to have to hide it too much security because you know,
it just,
it just see what people park their car and walk over and I seen it in Hollywood.
It was stories in Hollywood,
people robbing people outside of week stores.
You know,
now these weeds stores that are getting closed down there getting closed down by
the DEA,
like who's closing them down to the city,
the cities,
cities that the landlords are going,
we're going to find you every day.
So what a place I go.
You got to hire an attorney.
So for every day he stays open,
he's going to pay an attorney to keep them open.
And they just told me yesterday that the end of the June that done.
Why?
But there's still so many stores.
So what are the rules?
Were stores are allowed to be open and not open?
Is it like,
you know,
proximity to schools?
I know that divide.
Well,
this went down.
That was that they were the edible kings divine.
Well,
this and my eyes,
they always had something to kill.
A motherfucker that had the capsules that to Loris.
They had all the best shit.
And they told me they were moving to Canoga Park and there's new company came in
because they were moving because they were 500 feet from the church.
There's a church right on Lankershim.
So divine wellness is moving in Canoga Park.
They moved to Canoga Park and then some other motherfucker gangsters came and
said,
fuck it,
you're going to have to shut us down.
I think as the lay low,
whether they a saint so and they shut down and reopened for like two days.
What day?
What day they will walk.
So that would shut down.
Services are the future.
I mean it happened to San Diego.
It's all delivered tricky though.
Guys get set up and robbed.
Doing right now is,
I'm not smoking bill more.
It don't really matter.
I do the tubes of the morning.
I went to to,
you know the vape tubes.
I get there though,
girl scout cookies or a vape pen and then by one o'clock I pop on edible,
you know,
so I could buy a box of fucking boobies.
Boobies or Milo sent me a box,
you know,
that's the thing though.
Belt director.
So it was you sending them a copy of your fucking license.
Don't mail it to me.
She knows me,
you know,
she knows I'm legit.
So
yeah,
I'm a big fan of the edibles anywhere.
I'll be getting so much.
I sleep better.
I put this different water and my sleep apnea machine and now the edibles let me
sleep a lot better.
Very nice.
And if you want her to stay constantly medicated,
you could be very functional with a small dose of marijuana.
Marijuana.
I've taught small apple knows I fucked up last week.
I got high before acupuncture.
That's fucking brutal.
That would be great.
No,
she even said something to me getting high before yoga dude that getting high
before you want to really appreciate we get high before yoga because you get
high from yoga anyway and if you get high and then do the yoga,
it releases some crazy.
You do fucking,
you get high.
You go to even beginning of yoga where I was going 45 minutes passes before you
even know you have like this a not a hallucinogenic trip.
You have a body trip,
you start focusing on your knee and you could actually feel the blood going into
your knee when you're high with the stretches.
Yoga is really cool and that's what they say.
They do the hot yoga with weed and it really kicks it up.
I've never done it.
Yoga,
I don't know,
art attack,
bring water,
bring cold water.
But the,
the good thing about the hot yoga is it really warms you up for stretching
because when you're cold it's very difficult to stretch.
That's why I like doing anything like real strenuous early in the morning.
It's tricky.
You got to really make sure you warm up.
When I lift weights in the morning,
a lot of times I do,
I start my day by lifting weights.
I take a lot,
I take 20 minutes to warm up,
20 whole minutes of like light kettlebell cleans,
like swings and cleans,
like light body weight squats,
stretching,
touching my toes,
moving around.
Kangol the blood flowing because you got to think for eight hours or whatever
you sleep for.
You're just sitting there while everything's just the lying flat.
I mean your blood's pumping and everything like that,
but there's no movement so everything's kind of stiff and weird.
That's why when you wake up your back,
Herb's and if you go to bed for like two seconds and you lay down,
your back doesn't hurt.
But when you go to bed for eight hours,
you wake up and be like stiff and it takes you a few minutes and then whatever
that stiff and it is is gone half an hour,
so.
Right.
It's gone in a little while.
Got a warm the fuck up.
If you lift in the morning,
a lot of guys get hurt from that.
It's one of the main sources of injuries is early morning workouts,
but I have friends
that have 7:00 AM Jujitsu.
That sounds really cool.
At Dna of Jujitsu,
like fundamentals.
That sounds cool,
but not for me.
It's okay.
As long as it's warm.
I like 1130 11 I'm doing other things.
I've walked around I think nine o'clock my body,
but I would have a heart attack.
I'm really scared.
Well,
I have a big difference between like if I have a kickboxing workout at like 10
in the morning or kickboxing workout at seven at night,
God damn seven at nine I'm on fire.
I'm on fire real better.
Yeah,
it really,
yeah.
I like my shit over 11 o'clock 11 the one I've done eight o'clock for me to do
Jujitsu is fucking brutal about,
uh,
eh.
You know,
even if I eat dinner at four,
like if I know I got to go like Friday at seven,
I go to beginner Jiu Jitsu.
I eat a four.
So there's nobody of the standards.
That's how we got our snow.
Calisthenics.
We practice the technique.
We roll for eight minutes.
When the fuck out of that.
That's it.
What do you eat before you work out?
Nothing.
He'll take the whole,
nothing's less site.
Like if I'm going to do a log Jujitsu,
I'll take to uh,
shrimp,
Tasha text.
But I don't do the shoot texts every time I like to space it out.
I could tell the difference when I take a baby aspirin that will,
that takes true tech.
I see a big fucking difference.
So if I'm going to do something long that I'll do the shrimp tech.
If I to do something like kettle bells,
like just a short kettlebell workout,
10 sets of swigs,
maybe three cleans,
preset to cleans at a farmer's walk.
I just do a baby aspirin and immediately a protein shake with glutamine and then
one at night,
he's shaking his 300 calories.
I make them a water right.
The force
get a little bit of sugar in there too.
A little bit of a natural sugar in your dream died after a workout.
Yeah,
Replenish Your Glycogen,
your glucose,
you eat some fruit.
Fruit is good way to do it and do a lot of fruit.
Yeah.
Fruit juices with protein powder is a good way to do it after a workout,
but that's when you want to replenish like within 30 minutes.
But before I like fruit,
before I work out,
my favorite thing to eat before I work out as either oranges or pineapples
because there's a lot of fiber in them and I feel like I've ate like three or
four oranges and then have a good workout an hour later.
There's no effects like no cramping,
no weirdness,
easy to digest.
You know pineapples the same way.
He eat like a nice bowl of pineapple,
like an hour or so before I work out.
It never bothers me at all,
but you have the fiber from the plant matter and you have plenty of fuel.
You know,
plenty of sugar in your body,
but natural sugar,
you know it's shit kills me,
Joe Rogan,
but natural sugar.
You see when people have sugar,
if you have sugar from a candy bar or something like that,
that is the most unnatural form of sugar that human beings have ever created.
We figured out how to isolate sugar,
take it away from its natural plants and natural fruits and vegetables and then
process it and make it this weird thing that you could just add the stuff in
white powder.
You know that white powder that doesn't exist in the wild and the effect that it
has on your body.
Your body's like,
how are you getting so much sugar in this fucking thing?
I'll give you have a drink you ever look at,
like if you have just what,
you know,
one of those power,
those uh,
energy drinks or a,
you know,
post workout drinks,
hydration,
drinks.
Look at the fucking,
the labels of those things.
Look at a fruit punch.
Drink fucking red bull.
You good?
Have a seat.
We drink a red bull.
No you're not.
You'll have an express every now and then after a meal.
I like express it after a meal to like red bull energy drinks.
I don't believe I have enough energy to go on the sugar man.
The sugar's a motherfucker.
[inaudible] 75 grams of sugar and shit and you're like that.
That'll kill you.
That's terrible for you.
Like,
you know,
I can't even taste the regular coke.
It is horrific syrup.
Dun Dun.
Yeah,
she had a syrup.
Does that Mexican coke though?
It's a little better.
The,
yeah,
a little better.
But it's been a burrito place in Hollywood that sells those Mexico,
Laos,
you've got them everywhere.
They all get the bottles tastes better.
It tastes better.
Still not good for you.
I drank a no soda for three fucking bodies,
Bro.
There's a great documentary called King Corn.
It talks about the effect of a corn on your body and like how much corn they
have,
like how much of an influence corn has because it's corn syrup is used in so
many different products.
It's a fascinating thing.
We've got to get back to eating natural foods.
You know,
human beings,
we've gotten way off track.
We've made some pretty yummy shit with corn syrup and sugars and things along
those lines,
but people want to be healthy.
You got to get back to eating normal healthy foods.
There's just no way around it.
You got eat salads,
you got to eat fruits and for most folks,
eating meat is probably a pretty good idea.
Eat some healthy meats,
but these fucking,
the amount of power and the amount of influence that lobbyists and these giant
companies that push corn syrup and put corn syrup in everything,
the amount of income that they make from it,
like the profit generated from corn syrup was crazy.
Corn Syrup is in like 90% of our snack foods.
If you look around,
I just made that number up completely out of fat by the way.
But if you look at up like all the different snacks and different things that
have corn syrup,
it's fucking staggering.
It's off the charts.
That's some terrible toxic shit and it's everywhere.
But tastes great.
They tricky Joe Diaz.
Okay Dude.
This is a dude who's making,
I should say his name.
Uh,
he's making,
um,
all organic pot candy's now.
He came by here the other day.
Um,
he's got a company called,
it's called like a jumbo.
Yeah.
Jambo Organic Jambo.
I got to get you one of them.
They're fucking fantastic.
What sort of,
it's honey.
He doesn't with honey.
All organic ingredients.
No,
no.
High Fructose Corn Syrup.
No artificial sugars,
no artificial sweeteners,
no artificial flavors.
He's like the first guy to do these organic,
um,
pot candies and the great,
the great.
Not too strong either.
They don't kill you.
They're like half of a,
a Chiba chew.
You know,
when you don't get too nutty,
you'll probably take four of them.
But the craziest Chiba chew those.
So hide the bed.
There are book on production
of some Shit.
Wow.
They're making cash.
Sundash dog.
Those little fucking helmet was
the CBDS,
but the dad fucking little devil things really light you up like they really
scary.
I got to tell you the truth.
People who have injuries,
if you have an injury take like a cheap but you are half of Chiba chew and then
stretch out.
You'd be amazed at how good you feel.
You feel yours,
your muscles lengthening,
loosening up.
You feel things with half a deck and you go to bed.
You wake up feeling loose and the hash cookies,
they don't map them.
The more people are baking with them.
Well,
there was one company who had a Hollywood,
it was 20 bucks for two tiny cookies,
but every time I ate those things,
dog not hassling.
You realize that it was Bruce Lee was.
He has that because for the,
for the stiffness in your joints is shit.
I'm telling you.
When you eat hash,
you eat reef.
It's two different worlds.
Bruce Lee had some serious injuries.
He had a serious back injury at one point in time,
but he ate wheat for injuries like he ate.
We've specifically for the injuries,
well,
for medical marijuana,
it's one of the number one things that people use it for.
What's the thing of it was,
so it'd be,
yeah,
but the other one,
what's the other one?
When you work out,
you eat.
Let us take the acidity out of your muscles.
That's what it says.
A THC.
When you smoke it or whatever,
you adjust or whatever it takes to whatever out of your muscles after you were
like the guys that inflammation.
Yeah,
I read that might be a lot of bro Science,
unfortunately.
What's Bro Science?
It's what Brian Cowen does.
Brian kind of lay some science on you and you know he's not really a scientist.
I do it all the time,
Bro.
Sciences,
when you start reciting shit that you heard online pro the fucking,
the thing with THC it does is it pulls the lactic acid and then you Google it
and it doesn't do any such thing.
That's bro sides.
What is that?
A Blue East egg blue is Stephen Dorff.
You should do that goddamn commercials.
Joe Diaz,
you know,
I mean you,
you smoked that thing,
but you're done completely with cigarettes for a long time.
You don't worry about relapsing back to cigarettes by sucking on that.
No.
Can you put that down?
Yeah.
How long have you can go without one of those three or four days?
No problem.
Done that before I go because I'm talking to you.
I'm loose,
but it's not aware of me loose.
I can't smoke weed in here.
I don't really drink coffee.
I want to do something.
Don't listen.
I've always wanted to do something.
I don't want to seem like a cop in the fucking room.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't drink.
How creepy is that?
I'll take us.
I tell you what.
I like to always take at least one fruity drink at the ice house.
I can't do that.
No Wall.
The Ice House is great.
The bartenders are great.
The waitress,
this is a great,
you know,
go to the Ice House,
to the Ice House.
I could go for a drink at the fucking ice house.
Rub Up that the idea.
I was craving a beer for three days.
I walked around craving a Budweiser cold.
I crave cold Heidi kids.
Why do you have one every now and then do you don't like to drink?
I forget.
I forget to stop and get a BS.
Listen,
I will never ever drink and drive like you want to see me flip out.
Let me have a drink and before us to drive.
Cause I know I can't keep it together in front of a cop and I know that I could
never,
I'd have to cop to it like how stupid am I drunk?
I drank a dry like I would.
I'm totally against all that shit and I'll get stolen that fucking dude 90 down
to one off because of guilt because I could handle it,
but I can't handle alcohol.
Well,
people think that being drunk and being high and driving a car or the same
thing,
that's ignorance.
It's not true at all.
You can smoke pot and do Jujitsu with no problem whatsoever.
No problem.
Smoked Pot and you're very coordinated.
Smoke Pot and something drops.
He catch it like a reflex is everything.
They're all there and last.
You're not used to it if you're not used to it.
All you're thinking of is,
I remember when I first started getting high,
Joey started making fun of me because we,
I forget what we did.
We,
oh,
I remember we went to the fucking Sunday brunch at the House of Blues.
Remember they had that Gospel Brunch.
Yeah.
And then that Gospel Brunches,
that's how we all went over there.
We all went over there and we were toasted to the gills.
It was like one of the first weekends I ever got high and Joey d is like,
look,
this is a fucking rookie.
And Cause I was going,
I can't believe a high right now.
This is ridiculous.
I can't,
I'm,
I have to sit here.
I wasn't used to it.
I didn't know how to deal with it.
Nobody knows at the beginning.
But if I was the same high right now,
I'd be fine.
Cause I know what that is.
It's a,
it's what you're doing is when you're too high and you're paranoid and you're
frozen,
you're frozen because you don't know what it is.
You don't know what comes next because this is going to get worse.
Am I going to get more crazy?
Oh my God.
How long is this going to last?
But when you're used to be in high,
you're like,
I'm just high dude.
Relax.
Everything's fine.
You know what it is.
You know the worst it gets.
You know the best against you felt the full,
the full range of the effects,
but you were laughing at me.
I'll never forget.
He's like,
look at his fucking rookie.
So fucking hungry.
We your first,
when you first get high you get so enjoyably Hungary and joy.
A bleed like this simple like a peanut butter and jelly sandwich is fucking
flaming mouth.
Yeah.
We're like,
and you eat it with a bag of chips.
What is your senses?
Right?
It's,
it's so you don't even breathe.
You just chew it like I have a giggling like I love to giggle,
Bro.
A couple of weeks ago,
I had a cookie and I was sitting there so fucking stone at eight o'clock at
night and I kept thinking to myself,
this is the same cookie Casey case of eight it was the week that it was.
It was the week that he was busy.
Then he went missing.
He died or something.
I felt so bad.
I grew up on fucking Casey case,
but then there was traffic.
I was watching the news that day.
There was traffic on the four oh five and I'm like,
oh my God,
there's traffic on the four or five they'll listen.
They said,
because the traffic was that the president of Israel was on the four oh five how
lock half of it down and all I kept thinking about was the president of Israel
knows about these cookies.
Casey Casey debate.
He's covered to la to get these cookies.
That's how I was.
I kept giggling at the thought of my thoughts.
That's hilarious.
That was happening.
I love that.
I love still giggling.
That's what I missed the most about being stowed.
Two girls go to a diner and laughing at the waitress,
just gay.
I ain't going,
boy,
he just fucking,
you can't control yourself.
Like I just saw that shit.
The simple pleasures,
wheat but simple black.
That's what I look for.
The simple pleasures of being too.
Look,
how many times have we been on the road when we've been in the middle of
nowhere?
We're were in some town and it's all of us.
You know,
I was like,
you,
me,
Brad,
bad,
Ori and bill,
get bold lasted and then we'll go somewhere and have a giggle fest.
Like especially when it's all of us.
You know when we have a good group of like two or three of us and we go
somewhere on the road and you get really high in some town,
it's like we're all in it together.
You know,
we're lucky sitting in Starbucks or eating lunch somewhere,
he or Joey Diaz at,
we're all stoned and we're trying to get the gps working and asking me meltdown.
Well,
that was when Joe,
Joe used to have,
when you were at your heaviest used to have food meltdowns.
When you would land,
you'd have to eat right away.
Do I get anxiety?
I was getting anxiety,
but it wasn't not when we remember when Austin,
you were yelling because we were trying to find someplace to eat those little,
I couldn't do it.
It wasn't just sugar was I just wanted to get to my room and fucking figure out
how I was going to do blow bro.
Was that what it is?
But you were eating well.
We went to some place.
I wasn't doing blow the daytime.
I didn't have time to ride around.
Listen,
when I get off the fucking blame.
I got this time.
You've already got this tie with me.
How would you set that up?
Did you have like a network?
Yeah,
people voices as you get the tongue just talking about it on stage,
but I mean like say if you were going to fly into Austin,
like say if you needed,
you needed coke.
Did you already know people that you'd get coke from land you covered?
We're going to come see you.
And that was code for,
we're bringing it.
Uh,
so I do,
but I didn't know at that time at Austin.
I just,
still to this day,
I have flooded anxiety.
When I get off a plane,
I got time to dilly dally.
I don't want to walk.
I don't want to talk.
I want to get to the root.
Let me go upstairs.
Let me take a shit.
I'll be checking and be relaxed.
Then we'll do whatever the fuck you want to do.
Forget the fucking gps.
We should've got a car with a driver to get us through the whole top.
I ain't got time to land at four o'clock.
The fuck would go in the traffic with GPS.
Till this day.
I dread landing in lax after 12 other Sunday.
I won't do it.
I'm going back to Austin.
Uh,
I'm doing the,
uh,
I'm actually doing a comedy club this time because I'm preparing for my comedy
special.
So I'm doing cap city for the first time in years.
I haven't done cap city and fucking happy.
Those people going up the 15th and the 16th you know,
August.
Yeah.
How happy am I going to be?
I can't wait.
I love that place and I,
you know,
I love doing the theater there.
Last time I did,
uh,
Austin city limits when I was there this time.
Yeah,
I'm fucking pumped.
I'm,
I like mixing it up,
man.
That is a great [inaudible]
old real comedy club.
I really enjoyed myself there.
I Viv used to it.
Now the last four times I've been there,
I love them.
There's no better time.
Like Margie,
I liked the double tree.
I liked,
they've now they put you in a new hotel that's fucking funky or is she know more
doubletree?
Nah,
you're downtown and shit.
They rebuilt downtown you somewhere else and it was really interesting.
Papa Papa,
Papa goes,
Hey Papa.
Tito's is around the corner.
Yeah,
right up the street.
Right up the fucking walked in both of them.
Fuddruckers Fuddruckers yeah,
that's right.
[inaudible]
apparently you got it.
We don't,
but you gotta fuck with this.
There's,
there's some barbecue joints in Austin right now that are so off the charts are,
he said there was a line for it.
Brianna was three out has wait for three hours.
I'm not my boob lift.
Cuba,
listen,
Hey,
wait a little.
Yeah,
you could pay a guy like dollars an hour the way down if that's what he did.
I know that,
but guess what?
What?
I don't think they'll be sustaining the life for three hours for food.
I think they should stand on and I think when you get to the front line,
text me and I'll fucking show up and I'll give you 100 bucks.
They drive it to Joe,
they drive it,
drive it.
That's not good because then by the time it gets to you,
it's not hot anymore.
Plus you want to get it of his fingers in my brisket.
Yeah,
you don't want that.
You want to get it right when the guy pulls it off of the meat,
like boom,
puts it on a plate.
You want to be there.
While that all goes down,
Anthony Bordain waited in line just like everybody else.
I forget the name of the place.
I want to say Franklin or something like that.
Yeah.
We're almost out of time here to talk to you.
I love you.
I love you too.
You motherfucker.
Fuck this.
I got to take a water on the way up.
You can take whatever you want to take.
One of the CTO,
coconut waters.
I love you brothers started a sponsoring fighters.
I was watching a RFA the other day.
Some dude had CTO,
coconut water on his shorts,
so salute to you see two.
Oh,
thank you sir.
Awesome.
The fucking,
it's delicious coconut water too.
If you don't like coconut water,
try see too well,
because it's all with Thai coconuts.
Thai coconuts is a short plants like the Tom Cruise of coconuts,
so only five feet tall and they're super delicious.
It's like a sweet sort of,
it almost feels like they add sugar,
but they don't and just how it tastes.
That's right.
You can even have,
they even have some with the pulp if you like that chewy shit.
Yeah,
I try.
I like that.
It's not bad.
I like without pulp,
the bass,
but I liked,
I don't pass on the pulp ones.
I used a CTO and a lot of mixed drinks.
It's great for a mixer.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
Right.
Which I would imagine it tastes really dehydrated the same time you hydrate.
Yeah.
So I got a couple of clubs coming up in July.
I'm doing wise guys and Salt Lake.
Oh Shit.
18th and the 19th.
Almost sold out already.
Then I'm doing a San Jose Performing Arts Theater on uh,
26th.
Want to do that?
Oh Shit.
Reno buck a lot.
What are you doing in Reno?
Some club.
I little below the Navel,
but yet I'm doing American comedy company in San Diego to the eighth and the 9th
of August.
The first with you?
Yes.
The first ace ace theater downtown La.
That is uh,
August 1st me,
Joey Diaz and Duncan Trussell Sar cats.
And then,
uh,
August.
We haven't finalized it,
but it will be in Denver,
Colorado.
It will be at the comedy works and that's where I'm going to be doing my next
comedy central special.
And I'm fucking very excited about this.
Um,
my,
my favorite all time shit that I'm putting together.
I can't wait.
I'm really geared up right now.
I'm enjoying the shit out of it.
If you want to go see the funniest motherfucker on earth,
you go see Joey motherfucking Diaz.
Joey Diaz.
He could get them at w which were railroad next Friday and Saturday,
the Ice House if your local July 10th through the 12th to the San Jose and
problem up there for the Gracie nationals,
the regionals.
I'll be uh,
and then that next week I'm at the South Point Casino,
the 25th of 26 I think I've been reading all that.
It doesn't get any better.
You fuck heads and Brian,
you got anything going on?
Wow.
It got killed.
Tony this Friday with Joe Rogan and Dom Irrera and then Kinda Nice House.
Nice House this time.
10 o'clock ice house.
If your comics come at nine o'clock,
sign up.
Uh,
I a comic con 2014,
July 23rd and 24th.
Good Lord,
Florida.
August with Sam Tripoli three dates.
Oh Lord.
That's my new thing.
That's from the jungle,
Bro.
Be careful.
You might summon spirits.
That's real.
That's a real rattle.
Okay.
We gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
Thanks to uh,
naturebox.
Thanks to naturebox.com.
Go to naturebox.com/rogan and save 50% off your first box.
Uh,
thanks.
Also to tango to rogan.ting.com save 25 bucks off your first device tonight.
Ice House,
Ian Edwards,
Brian Callen,
Sam Tripoli,
uh,
Tony Hinchcliffe and mate,
you fox,
we love you and you love yourself.